all right we are laughs welcome to the i
lords podcast episode 100 100 lords we
it's another glorious Sunday we are back
at the roundtable on the Lord's Day I'm
very excited about our special guest and
we've got Reggie fils-aime a retirement
gay past and possibly scalebound or
switch anaconda and Lockhart to be
revealed at e3 halo Infinite and Mike
Ibarra and reviewers to discuss so we go
get right into it I wanna introduce our
Lord who is not only an amazing friend
to the realm but is truly one of the
most positive beacons and our entire
gaming community this law is extremely
high quality content and passionate work
ethic is synonymous with everything he
does yet at the same time exemplifies a
true selflessness and the promotion of
all his favorite fellow gamers
introducing the host of breakfast with
bull game news at noon Xbox Factor and
the double barrel gaming presents
podcast one of our favorite panelists on
the crossfire podcast and the New York
City Lord also raised under the tutelage
of mr. Lee's video game trading of New
Rock City making his return into the
realm of the Lord's mommy
Lord bulls stick Excel how you doing sir
hey man that was some write-up man you
know let me tell you something I do a
lot of these write-ups just like you and
I learned from the master and that was
awesome it is an absolute honor a
pleasure to be on episode 100 I am
stoked to be back here we're gonna be
dropping some massive info you know news
today I thought I've been kind of been
keeping up we've all been keeping under
the wing about something that's coming
up that's big a lot of big topics a lot
of emotions man on an Internet I don't
know I mean you know again I say this
all the time you know we were talking
pregame how I can
myself now an old-school G I mean I'm
two years away from 50 right so I've
been gaming a long time and I say this
and I really do mean it with absolute
respect I have had the privilege and the
honor to watch gaming change some dots
and sticks to where we're getting now
with photorealistic graphics and you
know in all those 40 plus years I've
owned every console and I really mean
I'm not rich I've always been a guy
that's worth like two or three jobs a
king talk bull don't be an irate and I
have I've again I when I wanted
something I put my head down and I got
my hands dirty and I did what I needed
to do and of course mr. Lee took
thousands and thousands of dollars from
me with the import and I got I have been
privileged to own every system from the
NES moving forward as I paid for myself
everything and and you know change
happens yeah big change happens and as
technology advances you know we went
from cartridges and CDs and DVDs and
blu-rays and now everything is digital
and it just seems as if people and I'm
not mentioned anybody I'm talking about
the JIT it's a general statement of
really having those that's something in
the fields yes where if you are starting
to agree with this you know the
nastiness is starting to come out and I
got to say that that's a bad look for
some people will get into as we go into
the show you know sometime like you say
we've been around a long time and the
industry evolves and it's sometimes you
know a lot of people are resistant to
change and it just you know stuck in
their ways as far as things you know we
don't get into that because I know where
you're going and I can't wait to get to
that subject but all first of all glad
to have you on episode 100 only right
and also you're like one of the hardest
workers of showbiz
Thanks pwhen Etna realm with it no it's
you know and lasting would have you been
playing sir very well I I've been
playing you know the February 15th came
and of course boom bean boom who buys
everything or at least tries to I was
able to snag Metro
crackdown on game pass anthem and far
cry new dawn i-i-i plowed through crack
down listen I'm gonna say this right now
no fanboy here and I did a special
edition episode yesterday I gave it a
7.5 I thought I couldn't a fanboy doubt
and gave it an 8.0 but I what I wanted
to do it the right way and give it the
game the what I was reviewing so I gave
a 7.5 it is an amazing game from start
to finish especially in the
single-player the multiplayer yeah sure
like a lot of multiplayers needs work
I'm almost done with Metro which is the
sleeper wow-wow-wow
a sleeper hit of 2019 I'm hearing
fantastic graphically the HDR on the
phone on a 4k screen on the X is just
magnificent and it's it's it really is
it's gonna be in some people's circles
for game of the year 2019 that's how
good it is I'm hearing fantastic do you
wanna pay the bills right quick
shout-out to Lord Cedric H with the $5
super chat
he says 100 episodes congratulation
lords and shoutout Lord boom oh thank
you man notice rate that age man much
appreciated thank you sir
oh man Lynch Pitt Wow with the $10 super
chat nice it's live and there could be
no better guest than the incredible boo
wow that's nice able to say thank you
Lord Germany's gonna build a wheel 800
that really means a lot to us but yeah
boo so you've got you got Metro up there
right yeah okay so you already know you
know saying it's the that four horsemen
again we're down and Lord we're down a
Lord so it should have been five
horsemen today because we got a special
other special guests but um it's for
hopefully our Lord addict in the wastes
of West Virginia they nuked his power or
but there's no way separates the rest
but it's always something Midwest bwv
even hit the channel probably was
Virginia
Eric may hit me he's so he's really sad
cuz he wants to try to make it hopefully
these guys get their power up brother
hopefully you can join in progress
because it's gonna be late lick
I got you Eric and of course we still
had our most technical gaming Lord the
solo gamer who lives for the single
player selfish experience and also the
sastra darkness mister off my profile
Illuminati in law patron of the iron
bank mom made Lord sovereign are you
doing sir I'm telling mantle real good
got a jump inside cuz that again here
you know that we needed that today
telematics you got to play some stuff
this week um so yeah play some more
crackdown crackdown is great cuz you can
just come back to it for 15 even you
know a half hour 20 minutes at a time
yeah and honestly like I think in a half
hour that I played this week I must have
collected like 30 orbs like so you get
something done all the time maybe even
in short bursts so so I'm chipping away
at that I got more into Metro mmm like
when we're saying like a pet peeve of
mine with games generally the coming
towards the end of the generation they
have to do something about uniformity
when it comes to HDR in these games like
boom is right the HDR is great after
they fixed it and yes it's like you know
everybody has did a different way of
going about it and they don't explain
that well to the gamer and then when it
comes to the tools used to measuring it
on a game game basis it's the same thing
it's everything is up in the air some
people have great tools some people have
horrible tools we need to get some color
uniformity because the HDR is a game
changer that not everyone is able to
opinions are you saying that some people
have opinions I know exactly what no and
you'd be surprised I actually got a good
10 hours into Anthem it's a long game
some things to say real quick what I
liked about it the the locomotion the
flying that's great
everything about that is great is
intuitive very easy it is truly Ironman
simulator um when it comes to the
shooting feels good the weapons don't
feel great they don't feel super um
unique
yeah in terms of the weapons so far
anyway I don't they don't seem super
unique not not in a way like a destiny
weapon feels right um in in terms of the
looter the looter shooter stuff that I
think it could do better I I think it's
a mistake not to have your javelins
upgradable in a way that affects
gameplay especially for a paid looter
shooter um uh you know you in destiny
every little piece you know whether it's
your your guns and how you how you
change up your guns or your or your on
the armor and stuff like that all that
stuff matters and except for cosmetics
on the javelins none of it really
matters I mean I know you can add stuff
to it and and make changes to it but I
think if if they focused on making the
armor super special like piece by piece
and stuff like that I think that's
that's a huge part
of that that loop in that grind I think
you guys like in destiny that I think
it's absolutely missing I got I got a
conversation for that too and then in
general to say it doesn't feel like a
Bioware game it does you have a
perspective because you you Bioware vein
yeah I think so I I hear what you go
yeah I'm disappointed in that it that it
doesn't feel like a Bioware game like
the just the very minimal choices that
you're giving much one second that's
what I'm trying to convey to the parties
we'll be talking at her because he never
really played by way of games like that
prior right and you got understand for
us our standard is so high we came from
the Mass Effect's we came from the
Dragon Age you know what I'm saying so
like not to see the dialogue choices
about like okay how's my dog today and
you know really you don't say like it
really don't affect it yeah it was
tacked on almost like it's not you know
I mean it does yeah it doesn't feel it
doesn't feel like if you look at the
initial videos they showed of game plan
would not even when you're walking
around for Tarsus and like you you're
talking to NPCs they have emotion and
they have emotions like that you can see
it in their face like they change up
their facial expressions and stuff like
that and when you're playing the actual
game that's not quite there and
everything feels sort of stiff and just
very robotic in a way that doesn't feel
at all like a like a like a Bioware game
so I think in that respect they they
kind of throw it a little bit that's not
the game that they give but in terms of
I think a great core is there I really
want to see what this game looks like in
a year um but it has some work to be
done
and King is laughing because he's not
sure the game's gonna be around all you
ever really speak like that was that and
of course we have the Incredible Hulk of
this aka the excess gamer ooh the lord
of combat sports who was a man of his
convictions demands nothing less than
the premium experience and is the leader
of the fraud alert movement ooh
lovely lord k guy you doing sir oh my
god today boy do you understand like
when I got for work oh man I ran
straight in this house I see he ran
straight downstairs to the PC and turned
it on I said you're not gonna get me
today bro he's not gonna be your day
that you're gonna make me late today bro
this is it cuz I'll be there early but
the PC be like you have to wait that's
mr. Lee trying to get some more money
out of you brothers it is that's nice
only the king so salute to my brothers
for real this has been fantastic the
ride has been incredible I'm also going
to give a shout-out to a lot of people
in the community shoutout to Thanos I
said I won't say your name
Nadeau behind the scenes and you know
like to be upfront so I respect that and
I'm not gonna say your name shout out to
Tim dog Wow that's my brother from
another mother
puns alright um shoutout to Megatron oh
bloody knuckles shout out the super-g
yes sir yes I don't decay mega gasps yes
um boom is here so I got a shadow we got
a new everybody that's gonna be at the
compound axe
oh man shut up the hip-hop gamer
yeah shot the hip-hop right um I
definitely want to say shout out to my
brother because my brother has
definitely put me a position to win yes
sir right without looking for anything
in return and that's a real brother that
does that for you
- from the very beginning I don't think
a man or shout out the tip network cow
yes album without tick network and
giving us a platform to show what we had
and my humble opinion I think chal is
one hell of a man
i yo Rashad mad respect s gosh out dizzy
on a path for this so I'm a shadow
people that's here drinking all the
stream team know who else am I missing
potentially perfect but sold potentially
if I miss anybody
y'all know tweet or strike to say you
forgot mr. Lee
that's it baby nice it tastes beautiful
oh it's like $500 birth this week this
week I played crack now that yo okay
what anybody says that crackdown is so
fun I ended it right and also it's hot
fire all right anybody don't understand
what hot fire years
stick your hand and hot fire it's hot
fire fire that's exactly what it is I
know a lot of y'all in your feelings you
feel like oh no King your fan boy no no
nobody ever told you that it was gonna
be anything other than what it was
crackdown and it played just like crack
none that multiplayer separate dining
I've been about that yeah they do that
in the box for y'all because y'all made
a big hoopla about a Microsoft made oh
man we got caught out there we don't
have it this way the clouding really
like the cloud save is mystery talk to
sovereign sovereign over cloud better
than anybody else home so that game I
ended it with def sing at def
was only in the game probably two and a
half hours I finished the game with 12
and a half hours in and I dragged him
through to the end so he didn't do
anything else in the game but ended it
he I have a great time um I play some
black desert
I ended titanfall so I can stop being a
fraud um oh man that game there's so
many great games that we have just like
boom sad we came from sticks and lines
and a little boy from here mm-hmm I did
the same thing boom did I played every
system I went all the way up so when
PlayStation PlayStation you know get
your diaper changed we spent two days in
line you know what so please man I
remember when Maddie had a little ball
heads in the eyes was black i lo
what a feeling run everybody over I
remember gaming day how about that
all right um and I used to look forward
to everything so so so stop um these
guys are in a feelings nowadays and I
see it I played this anthem right and
I'm gonna tell you about it oh all right
here we go anybody that winning out
there and spend that $60 you got scammed
right that's that's that's a deep pocket
hold up you got a deep pocket hold up
they ran up on you they put the hands in
your pocket and said stick them up and
you nothing but played it and you liked
it too so you're drinking the kool-aid
you want a coach you drinking the
kool-aid and you trying to convince
yourself the game is good it was not
good now it's better than that stupid
demo I don't know who was in charge of
the demo hopefully he got fired for
somebody to get fired but that man needs
to be banished you gotta be gone okay
that was the worst representation of a
game show like to show it if somebody
like hit play this and that was actually
you know is actually decent but that
demo the demo
turned me off completely had me
completely biased towards the game so I
played the game we're gonna have ta
access and if you don't utilize your
xbox that's all you P
if you've got game past EA access all
that stuff that you can't get no place
else don't cry to nobody talking about
they ain't got games you don't have
money um so let's get back to that that
that part right there right where I'm
playing anthem I'm having a good time
but you said all this cosmetic stuff and
it's not changing the gameplay I switch
to a gun really it felt like division
mixed with destiny destiny to with the
gunplay of division with some aspects of
destiny with a flying mechanic okay that
is like a mishmash of different things
yeah but they do it all bad they do it
all bad because okay come on come from
like that what type of loot a shooter
hmm is it that when you go to loot you
can't see your loot yeah that's a that's
a bag I have to agree with ya thing I
don't like ISM the discouraged bar give
you this with the discourage of
exploration when you're trying to loot
and look around and if you're poor you
got that sinister like party goes too
far ahead and then the whole game pulls
you give you that countdown hurry up
hurry up
thirty seconds we're gonna bring you
know I didn't know what that was right
and I'm flying in a group my stupid
behind wander to the left good they are
at the mission over there and it saw
something on the screen it said you to
far away something I said did they just
stop my fun
they didn't move me from me looking in
the bush and I was over there in the
bush trying to figure out what's
happening in this corner over here I
wanted to figure it out but they do who
want to lead the pack want to drag
everybody forward so mmm win-win what
was that game for Xbox tech that came
out stated decay yes yes they did decay
to yes yeah what they have added
feathering yeah
go way too far did it yes is this one a
four-player co-op game that kept you in
a tiger you all right you're right there
wasn't that same energy again game is
doing it so see the hot pocket stick up
that's going on right now and you're
drinking the kool-aid good it's a night
you're dying slow very slow like
sovereign said you won't have to wait
until next year to figure out if it's
really good okay all right
and I hope it's around that long I hope
you'll stick around and hope you'll play
because you ought to say do they play
destiny on the first upload and they
yell out you know I just want to jump in
for a second cuz I agree with King I
think that anthem has a process and I
got the Legion of Dawn Edition so I'm
all-in you know there's no tipping the
toe when I jumped in and it was cold as
[ __ ] but you know you know the thing is
this you know Division two comes out in
a couple of weeks I'm trying to say
Washington DC has already sent me I got
the watch bro and mail it up and it my
mission package has already been sent so
when that comes out I'm sorry the same
way I saved New York City I'm gonna have
to take the train or hotfoot it over to
Washington DC I think I think it's in
real trouble because you know there's a
listen destiny one came out where it was
right you know 7.1 Metacritic everyone
and it had its problems but at the same
time give Bungie credit where credit is
due that gameplay was tight I assure
there was some things that needed to be
fixed but there was a gameplay loop that
kept you in yes go ahead dude but I had
I talked about on the last word is
bounties and I was going it's out to my
brother Philly Eagle he was in a chat we
were kind of discussing this and I said
look for the people who did that we're
just hating destiny fans are just hating
way look at Disney chomping at the bit
he can't wait to get it
oh you're talking to an to slander y'all
talkin looter shooters and I'm just like
no that shout out the borderland but
what it says is that like listen for the
people who think that the destiny fans
are just hating on anthem and destiny
had the same issues in a launch here's
the fundamental difference the issue is
when you play destiny at launch
Vennela 1 there were no technical issues
prevented you from playing the game the
gameplay was tight there were no bugs
there was no respawn issue there's no
loading screens from a technical
standpoint for a functional standpoint
the game worked now whether you had
issue with the story but in that issue
with the content more content that's
another issue that may be justified but
that's the fundamental difference the
game works and they see it go through
these things and you just you just hope
boom that at a certain point that not
only it able to correct these things but
they continue with the content you know
updates in the content trains and stuff
like that otherwise if you said you know
you got division coming you know on
what's called st is gonna reload with
their season of The Drifter and season
or redacted and stuff like that so be
interesting to see but sorry kinks are
boring interruption oh no no no me but
you but you're right yeah you're a
hundred percent right I mean I think
those are they're in trouble 20 division
package the big boys status package
shout-out to Microsoft and Discover Card
I told you guys how to get game for free
also a purchase Red Dead now I told
y'all I told y'all two things I will get
Red Dead when Red Dead is on sale y'all
said right there to never be on sale
well xbox had a register read they're on
sale 30% off guess who jumped in that
water available through available when
it comes to stuff that I don't know
about and I'm just now I'm a drink I'm
not the cool a drinker rightful let me
sit there talking about waters wet let
me find out myself listen Kay we just
saw you drink champagne we know you
don't drink no damn cool a
all right so I put it on now this is
discussing a bottle or me when I get out
there you understand that listen Kelly
family yes sir
Requin yo yes sir Oh sir at the ruler Oh
cally realness correct sir many music
mani music all right the beats many of
them beats is crazy
sure Lavery oh listen we have such an
extensive family if I ever forgot
anybody I didn't do it on purpose
thank you guys all right here we go see
y'all baby mm-hmm all right so I put on
this um red dead right and I'm a
spaghetti western nut I'm not fool I'm
that dude right and I'm looking at it
and I'm like oh man this is not the game
not the game looking like this I said oh
my god it looks incredible I hope your
night is the are of the no you need turn
that off is history broken look even
better it's not even a subjective thing
is broken
yeah ox I don't know what they do with
it on and it did stuff like God of War
right now you're not only God of War he
teaching his boy with that bow yes oh
boy
so we needed to go hunt and he took me
out with a boat and I said
here's two takes on the same scenario
mm-hmm but one felt like it had gravity
yes all right it felt like the open
world miss this is this is and this is
no slander to a god of war this is when
you say game of the year type of
credentials mmm
remember I'm rolling with spider-man to
the death to the wheels for wall sounds
like he's changing there no the fact
that I put my fingers in this game and
I'm seeing the mature content I'm seeing
a spot-on with the aim assist people um
it felt like a bonanza episode it felt
like yeah you know that boom you're what
I just said I said the man yes right you
know what it felt like
who's not playing this game who hasn't
touched it
mm-hmm you haven't touched it I don't
care what type of game are you are right
you owe it to yourself to touch this
game you owe it to yourself to see
greatness in its rare Oris form in its
realest form when you touch it the
Eleanor Attic was talking about when
who's aiming down sights the game has
granite movement it feels a little stiff
sluggish that's his it don't because I
was moving through snow but when I was
moving on the ground
I felt like ground you know so my
opinion of the game is this so far early
on Chris was explained it to me that I
had to do a whole bunch of stuff the
game looks like I'm going to have such a
good time with it I'm happy that I got
it for free
because I got my points from discover
nice and I went over to Microsoft and I
purchase after I got from Gamestop you
know I tell you how to hustle use the
stuff when I buy everything get free
points and go buy games for free
okay that's right um that's what gave me
and stuff all right
um but this game I see I'm gonna
probably be sharing sovereign's opinion
of the game when I'm finished with it
and it's so early on the greatness is
there I didn't want to tell anybody I
was playing the only person I knew I was
playing it was Chris and I played apex
this week so I had two games and I
started a game and I'm going back into
my backlog to tear up these games to
stop being a fort and be teased real
attic would be proud
thank you sir and of course we have a
Lord who truly needs no formal
introduction as one of our day one
supporters in the realm this Lord is an
arc tribal leader by day but also a
fellow destiny warlock and anthem storm
javelin by night live from the Lone Star
State and Lord of the playback game
evening network mommy
lord I dizzy 81 are you doing sir I'm
doing good I'm doing it I had a kind of
like be quiet because my gaming tastes
obviously are on the the opposite of the
spectrum
I'm definitely so what I've been playing
I have been playing it so dumb I here's
what I'll say I agree I have been having
a fantastic time and my experience is a
little bit different than I think that
what a lot of other people have been
doing I have to agree with some it
doesn't live up to violet and what you
would expect from a by working despite
my personal belief of how I think my
wear is I think that they're better
Studios as far as campaign driven games
I digress it's definitely not what you
would expect out of a typical Bioware
game so I feel like that they have a lot
of the story elements I've been running
to do this story itself a lot of it it's
just it's very boring it's very dull
there's a lot of chatter going between
you know some people there actually I
feel like Owen and the young city I feel
like the he's pretty captivating
whenever you hear the talking going back
and forth there's a couple people like
there's one guy that you keep coming
across and he keeps hitting up and then
he starts telling you about all the
moves he's putting on everybody else in
the
the whole tower whatever it's called
right I'm like this is borderline sexual
harassment so there's certain things
that are pretty good um I I absolutely
love this form but I feel like that the
majority of everybody playing the anthem
right now is loving the storm every time
I jump into a match it's easily 2 to 3
storms per match yes so I guess I'm not
as rough on him but also I come from an
art background so I'm used to dealing
with the bull you know we're we're lied
to about what you're gonna get and then
you don't end up getting my story three
stages pretty much so I you know we'll
see what goes on with the game um I
think that anybody who is used to the
style game you know Bungie prepped you
for it no it's not going to be for the
casuals this is going to be for the hard
court individual who likes this genre of
game who's gonna stick around and of
course you know we see that with Bungie
getting the resurgence with the hard
court of course testing - or division -
coming around the corner these are a
gang in that sort of John if you were
looking to play a little shooter that
has everything put in the package you
don't have to wait on anything you need
to go by that handsome jack collection
play it over their destiny and anthem
and division - or not for you they all
were from P hey subtract go no buy that
wait for the new one to come out you
know so I've been playing an anthem I've
actually been playing uh I've been
playing Pokemon the let's go it's
actually been a fight with my son my son
right now only he's over here trying to
wrap it
[Laughter]
so I've been I've been kind of like
fighting with him and everything you
know like I'm just gonna be playing you
know it's clearly you know so you know
in you know kind of I know it's kind of
like segwaying away from what we're
talking about with you know anthem and
all the new stuff but I it started
making me reflect you know the Pokemon
go let's go it had a very bad rap in
I've actually started thinking about
things like a scores you know we look at
the Kirby game for Nintendo that came
out of the the Donkey Kong low scores on
these but here's one thing that I've
been noticing this kid has not been
noticing anything as far as a score he's
been having a blast playing these games
that's what matters oh they mad you know
so jump into what we're looking at now
what we're talking about these scores
are going into these games and stop
looking at the scores and stop because
you know everything was based on a skill
you play it like is what you like like
it doesn't matter what you know
so-and-so says about a game you're
enjoying it enjoyed that game please
Crystalis lady stop jumping on the
social media reach waiting about
somebody didn't enjoy it yeah you know
it's a mob mentality cinema destiny
thing I'm used to the slender you know
there I was I was told not to enjoy my
game there's nothing stopping me from
playing that so at the end of the day
it's like you said it's like people I
think look for validation on their
purchase and what happens is if they
don't get it from the mob you know I'm
saying a lot of people feel away it's a
lot of anger back and forth and stuff
like that also on the flip side people
that just you know don't like a certain
game okay cool but you know you don't
have to attack someone that actually is
enjoying shots the people playing
fallout 76 I see people still enjoying
it yeah jazz Gordon and you know my crew
and stuff like that anchorman and them
guys I'm saying they still playing it
like it's just that people have to
understand you is just not for you it's
okay it's okay
but that's what you got this man
crackdown you know let me take this
I'm gonna call I don't have a light to
say fraud alert right now hopefully he's
listening so I invite him to addicts
crackdown amen let's try this co-op so I
jump into this right
behold we're at the end of this my guy
is a low-level guy by everything like I
need to go figure something out so I
jump into my arsenal I grab all of these
these explosive rounds of yeah I got
nothing but grenade launchers and rocket
launchers on me so we're at the end of
this I had no clue that we're at the
very end I was like oh this is the last
one jeetu like I did death yes pretty
much so this man you know this man jumps
on this platform mm-hmm his character
gets stuck in the platform no here's
here's what's awesome mmm hit but he
also can't hit nobody Here I am dying
like every three seconds having to run
out blow everything up die again respawn
back in run back up there you know it
just became at you I'm not gonna say
he's frauding on this and everything I
just thought it was pretty funny like I
get driving this is the second time this
has ever happened to me though the first
time it's ever happened to me was
actually in Borderlands a friend shot me
an invite I jump into there they beat
handsome jack or whatever the last I
didn't even get to see who the last boss
was I jump into there and I get it I get
a things saying that I meet the boss I'm
like what what's going on here
so no movement fell isn't wrong show
nice let's do it wait wait is is is does
this he has an announcement
no what we gonna get today oh come on I
mean the whole situation
I'll see us all represented Oh get to
the shot teespring hit that up we'll get
that and of course we have the Lord of
the cooperative experience in gaming
ninja himself there's no B Lord kognito
spreading that release in the realm of
the ILP not telling you what you want to
hear but what you need to hear very
simple week I've been very busy on a lot
of projects with not a lot of gaming I
barely touched origami for the switch
for you guys want to get your 10 shoe on
I'm going back to the classes get your
true ninja Stealth please pick up
origami it's been on Xbox and
Playstation actually playstation for a
long time first Xbox recently got it and
the switch guys deluxe edition really
cool the essence of staying in the
shadows not being seen actually penalize
you for being in the light true ninja
stuff obviously a little bit of anthem
post day one patch you know lots of
improvement but you know we already
discussed the ADA we need to get into
that so I'm looking forward to what the
roadmap brings for them so now that
we've gotten into what all the lords
have been playing and Lord boom has
already been given the royal treatment
here in the round please check ILP 73
for hilarious episode kind of the best
gaming history's ever thanks to Gary we
feel very reflective so it's time for a
little reflection you know I love
podcast episode 100 this means a ton to
us and all the gaming laws all the
people in the realm will truly support
us every Sunday see y'all in the chat
you know no saying we really a
perspective she ate all the love show
whether it's the retweets on Twitter the
patreon support the t-shirt merch love
you know say everybody see the kress out
there man a speed up out there you know
it's just really humbling you know I'm
saying to see how long you guys are you
know I mean and we're not the biggest
you know saying we don't got the most
views and all that but you know you guys
have been there from the very beginning
we respect that and on what all that
being said you know Lord is he's in the
building today
you know he's one of my day ones one of
the very first laws to truly appreciate
us back from a very early ILP episode
it's like me annex out the SWAT shout is
zero you know they're funny the original
we just try to figure out what we
doing we even know he was doing it you
know it shout this fish out the lady
panda a lot of y'all I see all the chat
really feels good so um you know shout
out the Frodo oh my god just other
people man Reaper the whole crew so um
yeah man so he had the foresight kinda
see our vision respect what we trying to
accomplish so lord dizzy I've been
rambling I got drinks of my hand
no nice but uh I want to give the mic to
you you know saying in reference to our
special announcement and maybe some hear
ye hear ye talk so uh Lord dizzy the
floor is yours sir we can we can yeah
it's definitely been a long time coming
uh you know especially you know saying
early on and everything
I mean anybody in the chat who doesn't
like coming in here every Sunday you
know this is probably one of the best
events all week long whenever you're
jumping on a YouTube or downloading
something from Spotify or Apple iTunes
wherever you listen to it it's
definitely one of those diamonds in the
rough especially in this day in media
where you get something that is real
it's authentic they speak from the heart
just very experienced they don't you
know somebody say like yeah how about
this you know and you don't get enough
of that because let's be honest we look
at this day and social media somebody
says that they're wrong about something
and then all the sudden it's I jumped to
being offended and I agaton company
defend myself so this has definitely
been one of those things in you know
once upon a time I ran a gaming blog a
website and everything you know I'd like
to you know my personal showed us you
know obviously he goes back you know you
know panda shot on the road oh I'm a
Reaper with his medal gifts yeah yeah
I'm getting to her shout out to Reaper
with his uh you know Metal Gear Solid
history
you know there's so many people back in
the day they were rock on this website
before the websites you're frequenting
now this was what was there and of
course Mike my compadre my second half
of that with playback gaming was Bella
rides you know no shout-out to her and
if you didn't know believe a child is in
store here I'll tell ya shout two little
ones little ones we've been cooking
about some stuff and everything and I'm
gonna give it an early shout-out to
somebody I was introduced to from
kognito and his name is high and high
every talented individual insulted you
wouldn't actually hold on but I guess
before you put that up let me go ahead
and let me tell everybody what we're
going to kind of discuss when we hook in
and what we've been talking about for
about to follow and cooking let's look
at this alright nice a special
announcement of a new website the you
all are gonna be able to go and frequent
and hear and see and read and get the
latest and greatest as far as content on
the Internet
this is something we've been definitely
been working on you know we've gotten a
lot of feedback and we've reached out we
actually have some great writers some
people do you probably never heard of
but these individuals are talented let
me tell you I've been I've been working
on websites and doing articles since
2013 and some of the people that we have
now I I'm still blown away they're like
wow somebody can actually put this art
and to written for
they paint you a picture that you're
able to see this is essentially what
we're wanting to announce the the next
step in that our Lawrence podcast is
getting that brand of the Lords of
gaming that meant nice decoration done
then we gotta log in right now check us
out man check us oh right the site put
it on a double screen while you look and
watch us listen hit them like some like
shot a lot of content up there like did
you say we get some tremendous talent
tremendous in so many people have
contributed we've got some some great
editors in the building one on let me
know how bad my english understanding of
the English language will not be handled
by Lord King nor the red pen right here
read an article say that's the bomb and
then exactly how I am understand have a
grasp of the English language and I
continue we will put the links in the
description a lot going on man
tremendous team assembled and are we
looking forward to uh to take this next
era journey with with dizzy you know he
like I said he's been with us from day
one and just to see this transformation
shot the more Hyde
man he's really world away yeah man I'm
a total income stop sharing don't link
up in the joint but um yeah man it
really feels good to finally launch this
thing for you guys and and just all the
hard work kind of paying off so I'm
gonna throw that link up in there for
y'all you know saying so definitely Lord
the gaming net out you know what I'm
saying and all may and looking forward
to this journey business we ready really
ready we all here you know let me say
something real quick man like be honest
like I hadn't get to say it
they're my mother's segment but um what
all of this means to me
like episode 100 just being able to be
on here with my friends and just talk
gaming for a hundred I would have never
thought any of this
we're gonna happen much less that you
know we're launching a website right now
this is incredible I have to give a big
shout out to you [ __ ] because you my
brother like I've never seen somebody as
motivated to do a singular thing then
you from the very beginning you've not
taken no for an answer
the moment you got a little taste of
what this thing could be you ran with it
and you've never stopped and honestly
it's been watching your motivation to do
this has motivated me even more I know
it you know bringing me in bringing King
in it just honestly dude I I don't know
how much you sleep how often you sure
did
honestly man like I I'm so happy to be
on this ride with you guys and to be
able to reconnect with my with my
friends my childhood friends in a
different way now it's really really
amazing the work I've been the knee
brother because honestly I never seen
anybody so passionate about one thing
then you hey I appreciate I appreciate
the fact that you brought me in on this
ride appreciate you already know so this
is this is the channel 5 evolution man
thank you alright
King man you already know you had to be
part of me we sat there we talked we
chopped it up every night we don't sleep
we vampires yeah I I don't I don't I
want you to understand how I feel about
you brother when you said that you
wanted me to come whatever the hell you
need in this lifetime I'm gonna be there
to help you support you all you need and
and I looked at it I said how can I
contribute in my way and at no point
time did you say no you got you got a
box and do your boxing ok cool you can
put that up and an encouragement in and
a push Leah listen let me tell you guys
something I
i'ma keep this 100% um I was suffering
with depression all right
and I've noticed it a lot in this
community a lot in our community big
times man that this is the reason why I
don't block people this is the reason
why I answer every tweet if it's unless
it's disrespectful if it's disrespectful
so you you are me any bushes and
speaking needle and this looking forward
to this hanging out with my friends
because we used to do this on Saturdays
so what we're doing is giving you a peek
into our Saturdays thanks alright and
and we have a whole is a whole bunch of
us it's more of an all so many of us
alright we try to get okay with it it's
just a lot of control Sinister's out of
control alekan is out of control you
know mister highs out of like it's so
many but um I got it I got a share
sovereign sentiment with your drive your
push your 100% effort has inspired me
thank you brother to be better every day
has tied me to push forward to put my
best foot forward if you may notice and
I want you guys to notice anybody that
plays with me offline and y'all are in
my chat you know is ninja this you know
every less other word is a curse and if
you are easily asleep brother do not
come in my chats
why don't we all right that's only
reason why I don't stream because it
will be rated X because all right I said
a lot of bad things all right when we
get this king and that's not the king
that's over there but my drive to be
better to not say one curse on this show
angry all the episodes is direct result
of this man in the respect I have for
him alright school its
subconscious level better won't come up
appreciate Java yet we had to keep it
take it back to the seat keep it PG bro
keep it PG
what your kids if you have a list of
yeah Oh King attics not here but I know
he feels the same way I mean really
amazing lot to hear you guys say that
yeah I probably don't sleep as much as I
should but um you know it's just that
it's one of those things that when you
enjoy doing something it doesn't feel
like work and you actually you get
excited you know saying like you said
King it's just more of an extension of
how our Saturdays used to be with all
you know all of us in the BX and just
Lincoln out playing games okay combat so
boom no you're gonna say trading games
going to the video game stores and all
that stuff but man thank you guys means
a lot salute to the chat thank you for
all the kind words thank you for
checking out the site thank you dizzy
thank you hi we got some show to do
because I'm getting emotional if you are
somebody who is looking to break into
the industry looking to get your
thoughts onto paper we're looking for
more writers we're looking for more
people who are wanting to do the same
thing that we enjoy doing we're looking
for news writers if you just want a
report about like hey I really enjoy
that the trash that is over there and
anthem let me report on this I mean let
me tell you all the updates okay so
we're looking for that so if you aren't
interested please do not hesitate to
reach out to cog kini iron Lords we got
the the handle for the website as well
we'll probably get the email out there
so that you could send an email if you
would rather do it that's all it
definitely don't hesitate we're looking
for you
absolutely absolutely thank you so much
man pleasure to have you on debuting
that solve we'll have another
announcement at the end of the show so
stay tuned stop by the job some balls at
the end but uh go of it
so oh yeah we had a poll last week last
week's polls are in and the people have
spoken to the question with the final
release of crackdown three and mostly
negative
use of the game do you think the Xbox
fan base should demand more from
Microsoft in terms of game quality
moving forward the winner at 49% of a
threeway ILP poll was the yes the damage
control for Xbox exclusives hurt the
brain code a second place 38% was the
dough by yourself is already addressing
with new studios most had no intention
of mine crackdown 3 group and coming in
that last place at 13% of the vote was
the I don't care it's all fun and games
until Metacritic rips my favorite game
the percentage for the last one step my
TV game up so I can see the game in his
all his glory at the for Tracy your all
we hold one away drag is TV oh happy
100th episode with the finest ooh Thank
You famous all video cleanup but shadow
allows you participated in the poll we
already know what it is so we go get it
to these topics y'all you know say a lot
going on in the industry and uh let's
first start off with a end of an era
Reggie retires so well yeah alright so
more than 15 years man the tenor of
America you know nearly 13 years at its
present
Reggie retires last day and the 10 will
be April 15th and then our Doug Bowser
the Bowser era will start and succeed
him kind of funny there you gotta laugh
yeah you can't write that stuff do not
write this you know pretty much you know
said pretty much a Nintendo his heart
forever he had like a little video up I
don't know if we saw the Nintendo
Twitter it was really cool and um yeah
he's pretty much said it was you know
it's been it's been a great run and yes
like
for his family's friends and stuff like
that and we did do some background shout
out to a lord hole we did some
background to make sure it wasn't no
funny play going on you don't say like
it was a real retirement like nobody was
getting pushed out none of that kind of
stuff based on the structure of how his
exit was so ah yeah so pretty much you
know he was been there since 2003 you
know I mean 2003 during that era during
the Gamecube in the Game Boy Advance era
and um yeah man he's just been a huge
presence to not see there so I want to
talk brace to the Lord I want to first
get it off with its far is you know the
impact of Reggie on Nintendo any
memorable Reggie moments Danny the Lords
have and then how do we feel about uh
Reggie and moving forward in
transitioning to the Bowser era you know
damned sin $10 super check everyone
hunter there was also one before thank
you so much much I cast a great website
thank you sir Lords of gaming dotnet I
will keep putting that link in the
description thank you so much so I'm
gonna give it back to you guys all feel
about this so bad alright something to
do okay it's funny right check this out
I want you to put the paw together
alright alright I it's being cooked just
for you I told y'all and you know Reggie
probably was like nah I don't want none
of the Xbox stuff over here on the
switch to hell to the no till made the
freakin calls he smoked whoever he was
gonna speak to they
brought red uniforms listen many let me
get this straight so Reggie resisted
Phil is rearranging people's
organizations no Phil is definitely
remove we're slowly hit it oh it's off
and they cut off III Oh Phil Wow
if that's exactly what they said they
said Phil ain't even going to e3
alright so cuz Bowser's in compliance
with the Phil program compliance oh he's
at the Emperor and he says rise my
friend Lords have described with the $10
suits at much love to the Lords of
gaming lords of gaming dotnet best intro
and again best chemistry most
interactive show on YouTube let's go and
he says aunt them down in the bush
positive I loved you to death
I loved us he's part of the old all agog
all right that's it I love Reggie - just
a new wave the new movement is they need
chat over here yes you wanna keep
pushing out Mario and thinking is good
no it's not good we gotta have this dude
over there away we got to leverage these
dude you start to see in this movement
the transition yes see really seeing a
master strategist in his element hmm I'm
telling you the force auto Reggie and
listen ready all of a sudden you know
how what happens everything was good and
they're ready black I got to spend time
my family it's too fishy for you return
and then next week oh my own game pass
or switch that's not a coincidence
rather
like where that was going and they said
well here is your papers Oh his slain
your favorite head of your corporation
pieces around and putting yourself in a
place listen
X up and y'all said it wouldn't happen
he passes on that PlayStation five who
did that for you again Dominus is out
here ready to go back I feel good about
field
oh my gotta be honest with you I
probably should have went first because
he just exploded the building and I'm
opening up the door to like just the
door frame it's like where's the
building cuz I don't even know what to
say no here's the thing
I'm an old-school GI I know we talked
about that before and I'll do you got to
give a shout out right here that's crazy
Oh Brad I will stop for them okay
podcast one of our favorite podcast
100th episode keep doing your thing much
love thank you brother bro Enrique
you've always been there from the
beginning man thank you so much for that
it means a ton to see you guys in here
to support your dudes man great show
I saw double barrel you did a great
special photo man just the way you did
it for us it was good to see got some
brothers over 1,000 as well can't wait
man thank you so mu continued you were
saying yeah you know here's the thing
you know they are industry leaders in
this in this you know gaming realm that
we all hang out in and you know
obviously Phil dominus is who he is
and he's changing Microsoft in a way and
what we're gonna get into that how
people's feelings are all bunched up but
you know the thing about Reggie is this
you know he's a corporate
dude he has been his whole life but
there was something really awesome about
Reggie he wasn't afraid to make it you
know to make fun of himself
thanks you know he he goes out he makes
these commercials you know for these
Nintendo Tree live events and you know
these Nintendo directs and him working
out you know him you know acting a fool
dressing up in costumes and he was okay
with that and the one thing I have to
say is that you know he loved this brand
this brand was number one for him he
cared about the fans he talked to the
fence okay he's not on Twitter like a
Phil or like a Mike Ibarra which we're
gonna get into or like you know an Aaron
Greenberg you know these guys are
constantly going back and forth the
community but he he did it in a
different way you know every treehouse
event you know started or ended with him
you know every every III was uh you know
it was something special that he did for
the fans and then he put the fans first
you know the Nintendo crowd is a fickle
one and they want what they want and
they're you know a lot of them are
longtime people like all of us like I
started I got my NES when I was fifteen
you know what I'm saying I've been where
I've been Nintendo had since then and I
still support them and I really enjoyed
Reggie um you know his his vision that
he had for the company where it's at but
you know it is coming to an end on the
15th a Bowser who is just like I said
you just can't write this stuff I mean
thousands taken over the building and
and and you know it it's funny you know
Carole King was making you know kind of
fun of it he was basically our shirt in
and like listen this is the way we going
well I don't want okay well here's your
papers go sign your position any walk of
life at work um when your boss comes in
and your boss tells you that we're
moving in this direction and if you give
any pushback what happens you give me a
sign right well here I get actually the
funny story about that I was a youth
officer for most of my career because I
grew up in the projects and I always
wanted to give back to the community in
a way especially to the youth so that's
what I did
and one particular they made a big
change like normally I did 705 by 1540
which is like you start at 70 and Bible
just before 4 and they changed the
school hours they wanted us to start at
9:30 and as much as I love the position
that just did not work for my home life
so the boss was like listen boom this is
the new schedule we can't make
exceptions for even though if you're a
dinosaur and I had massive time on I had
to take the knee and be like well you
gotta send me back to patrol because I
just cannot do this so as as invested as
I was into this community that I did I
Patrol for so many years and and being a
youth officer first before a police
officer I had to move I had to die had
to go back to just being a regular Popo
you know I'm saying and and that's
listen I don't know if that's what
happened but I have to agree with King
things circumstantial thing I don't
believe in coincidence and that King
doesn't either he says it almost all the
time he is not a coincidence kind of a
dude he's he's a numbers guy he's a
realist and he just got you got to kind
of put one on one together and say hey
listen the news breaks that next bunch
live and and game paths are going to
switch and then almost like the day
later he's retiring so I don't know I
don't know if it's if it was like okay
you know take the blue pill to stay or
take the red pill to go home I don't
know but I can say that it's it's
looking like he had a way that he wanted
to go and Nintendo has a way that they
want to go and they I you know what you
have to understand something there are
some underlying stuff I don't know if
we're gonna talk about it want to throw
it out there King you said something
about expert you know about chat do not
be surprised if Nintendo moves their
online completely over to Xbox Live to
get the chat say there for the next time
we gotta but that's a great point lord
busy what do you feel first let's talk
about Reggie you know any memorable
Reggie moments and then what do you feel
about them going forward in the Bowser
well I mean wait wait what bad can you
really say about Reggie I think that you
know looking over probably the last
decade and a half he's probably one of
the few CEOs of a company or in his
position at a company that hasn't had a
foot in mouth syndrome where they say
something like oh I need a backtrack on
this you know bang right so I think that
that's probably one thing we probably
should at least give and tip our hats to
he just doesn't he's not that kind of
individual Rob it's it's sad to see him
go and I agree with boo you can't write
a you can't make this stuff up when you
got a guy coming in and his name is
Bowser very first Twitter fake you got
up is Mario Luigi tied up Larry its
dizzy running with that what you just
said that pitcher luma I'm a symbolism
guy - all right and the real Nintendo
was tied up in the back I think that
yeah probably things are changing but I
mean there's can we also not like take
into perspective day I mean Nintendo
stocks are at an all-time high
yeah now's as good of a time to cash out
when you're on top who wants to cash out
on the bottom no mm-hmm I mean that that
can also have a lot to play into it like
I mean what working you really do for
the company at this point and everything
so I think that and also here's also
another thing to think about if you want
to be in their position I think it was
it the the sales management position
both of them work they held that same
position before taking their current
position so if you want to be in their
shoes that's what you gotta aim for
Nintendo clearly yes King good a picture
but the game award show mm-hmm I was
standing in the middle oh my god
well then go back to that episode
symbolism was crazy right that do any
are you saying it was gold silver and
bronze here please
that is why I tune in every Sunday I
just want you to know that that that
comedy oh I paid to I pay money to see
him I took the only King King he turns
himself over to it like he is no even if
he's gonna make you laugh and you don't
believe a word that he's saying his
belief in what I say enough I had this
conversation offline shout the Lord meds
I don't know if love meds in the check
me a lot as a child
he's not your king man you know he's
funny or the joke I say he's like you're
he only believing I say excuse me I said
don't get it twisted
y'all be thinking is Joe King believes
like this is not all comedy here you're
like King sorry and we will get the
strong I told you just oh all this turns
out to be true you're watching the book
unfold when it was happening my man fill
out his plan is saying no and he says
see you at e3 who continue so yeah so
conspiracy theories aside with Reggie I
mean what can you say about Reggie
and Reggie's best moment to me was his
first moment LA you know came out on
stage and he said my name is Reggie I'm
about kicking ass I'm about taking names
and that was it and then at that moment
you got to remember that
at that moment he came in at the tail
end of the Gamecube era GameCube wasn't
selling gangbusters like previous
Nintendo consoles I think the only thing
is so worse before that is probably the
Virtual Boy um so they needed a strong
face to usher in the Wii era and to be
able to sell what the we was to Avast
majority people and he was he was the
ideal person to do that his stage
presence his and his his love for the
brand which came out and everything that
he did was essential and being able to
sell that we yes and you know he's he
was indispensable in in this in that
whole era of of Nintendo moving forward
um so yeah I mean it's to me it
definitely can be an issue where he's
you know the Nintendo wants to move in a
direction that they maybe he doesn't
necessarily agree with um and it was
time to walk away I you know it does
make sense because not everybody's for a
guy who's been so focused on making sure
intent the identity of Nintendo is
maintained and is solidified and you
know when you think about Nintendo you
think about specific things you think
about first party you think about unique
Hardware you need to think about all
these things that you know Microsoft has
said and Tony has said is changing and
evolving
maybe his voice at this point in time
isn't what they need I love Reggie man
you know what the first thing to do to
dismiss a man is to call him crazy and
what but in everything that I have told
you it has been factual oh try to keep
watch it because you know what it is
everybody says you know um oh yeah
Microsoft fanboy alright I'm not a
Microsoft fanboy
I'm just watching a master strategist
work like flying into poaching key with
this guy has got out of his role yeah
got a pistol and he went to work listen
that this is the level of shambles the
Microsoft was in yes speak on it yeah
that's a fact look at it right you got a
look at all these other companies all
these other companies itself a sony sony
was at the part of bankruptcy when when
when that happened and then he riding a
sky rocket to the moon
all right now in doing the ride in the
sky rocket to the moon they gain fill
this thing now it was the tournament to
a dirty little project it was like a
resurrected is on you oh come on he said
fellas doing if you can't beat them buy
them plan what happens when you got deep
pockets that's what you're supposed to
do you play to your strengths what a
master strategist does a master
strategist will do the symbolism i told
you who was next up when he took the
picture he made sure he was in the
middle if you look at the video when he
walked he looked at his spot and when he
stepped on it he stepped on it with
confidence and you next to mole 800 good
viper strike Wow zebra Yoshi
congratulations 100 episodes here's to
one home get more within 25 super bra oh
man I got a drink for that whoa
thank you I'm gonna tell you we have the
best chat we are all right now I mean
listen I'll listen I'm not trying to be
disrespectful
I just love you all yeah y'all bring it
I love interacting with y'all let me
jump in because I got you y'all gonna
call me crazy but then when I'm right
young lady here salute can't can't I
back yet bro don't worry about Cali with
the $20 super chat a toast to the
greatest gaming podcast online today
Noah French blue that's how I do it it's
to the first 100 and the next 1000
episode frozen north of Yellowknife and
T Canada yo solo brother great thank you
yo you guys you guys deserve all of this
in ten times more listen I like I said
you
no it's funny you know this 100th
episode for you guys is is is a big deal
for me being here because you and the
brat podcast are two of the first ones I
started listening to when I realized
there was a voice on YouTube so see you
guys blow up the way you guys have and
to help you you know get there and to be
on this 100 episode mad props couldn't
couldn't [ __ ] would have done a better
person better human being like you boom
you've always been a supporter man it
feels good just really good like I said
sometimes we feels we not the biggest
but I don't have to be most loved yeah
and that means everything man so I'm
just gonna get it to my spill real quick
all shout the Lord Reggie going out on
top I remember him like he burst onto
the scene like so I'll say this like
energetic aggressive new direction for
Nintendo of America they used to but my
song is the Loki takes shots at the
competition oh yeah there were times I
mean when they'd ask him and interviews
are like you know um so what's this
about you're not having a 3d I was wrong
with you he's always hilarious and
they're like you could tell that man
loved this job you say so funny Reggie
story real quick was old getting a
chance to actually meet him at last
year's e3 so it's also our Sam Tolbert
my son we was waiting into a media
meeting I think it was on remedies game
control the new one so he's gonna do a
little behind the scenes with that so
then boy we just see these division
security agents start to roll in and
like they like surrounded Reggie in
formation as he came through you know
they sound like Oh tabs in like yo
Reggie's in the building kind of thing
so he came over you know I'm saying yo
first of all to start your Reggie is
tall y'all yeah that's what I do
yeah yeah not a small dough you know I'm
saying much bigger than expected in real
life shook my hand real gentlemanlike on
the introductions salute to the security
for not shooting me on sight when I
pulled up hey you know exam photo yeah
man like yo salute em but yeah I mean
you know he goes out on top whether or
not the reasoning I don't know about all
that photo at the other day look you
know it's crazy crazy resume and then
now we got to see about this Doug Bowser
right you know
cool it was our sales and marketing
forum I understand on the switch so uh I
think that's it's very important because
the end of the day like one of the key
factors for me
selling a smear switch was this seeing
that that initial Nintendo commercial if
y'all remember it y'all
it just it was so well done explaining
the functionality and the God and you
know Zelda he's playing practical
he literally grabs it takes it out to
thing he jumps on the plane and I sat
that I'm like yo that's me traveling I'm
always on the road I'm always going
somewhere and then to see him bust it
out he opened up the plane you know
thing and he's just he's gaming got off
the plane went continued now I don't
know about the rooftop party down nobody
yet nobody playing stopping a full-court
game of basketball and I appreciate the
sentiment what you were trying to do now
shout out to him you know again he seems
like you know he's got it he got it
together and shows the potential of the
system and how great it could be so on
it also helps that he's a Microsoft
apologist oh my god oh I got this whole
transition but we got a lot of subjects
to get into I'm going to start off with
Lord annex topic and get in suman's I
know you really want to do this so uh we
got some news your Xbox game past and
possibly the app to switch we hear in
all types of rumors about games coming
possibly Ori
cuphead like just all type of stuff just
rumors just coming out so initially a
source I believe is from direct feed
games yes and um yeah they pretty much
they have a real good track record with
the rumors and yeah they pretty much
says that Microsoft is are looking to
not only publish games or the catalog to
the switch they're looking to get the
Xbox game past entire library through
the magic of streaming and possibly
X cloud and then um yeah so this this
could even mean that natively
games that the switch couldn't even
handle like a deer's v Hale or whatever
you know could be done over you know the
internet so on
this is this is really interesting
really powerful stuff you know we've
heard the rumbling for a while you know
I'm saying so um I want to bring this to
the roundtable let's start off with boom
you know when all these news coming out
you know as far as on switch and
Microsoft and having that happen stuff
like that what do you feel about this I
know you've been in the crossfire you
know let me just say this first of all
if you do not want to get run oh oh oh
I'll let you go now to speak on it cuz
that's ridiculous Oh Sammy Prescott
brother 25 out of super check
congratulations on the 100th episode I
look forward to this podcast and insight
every Sunday I LP interaction on Twitter
discord and now the website keep growing
the realm see you laws that heap it off
you won't be an increase in Prescott
hey bro yo we linked up brother Hadrian
reporter thank you so much don't be in a
building with the Lord's that's the big
announcements coming all on the same
flying chariot that's the big one but
yeah you know what yeah you know what
real quick let me just start it out
there cuz and I said I was gonna make a
big announcement and and you know being
a gaming as long as I have you know you
have things that you've done and things
that you've never done and I have
personally never been to e3 it's always
seemed out of reach it's always seemed
like a daunting experience I would not
know how to do so after our episode I
believe you said it was 75 was it that I
was 173 you will 73 okay you know I
started talking and you know and and
when when I let the cat out of the bag
that we were all in the same hood so to
speak we just never really met in real
life and we if we did we didn't know I
started you know I started you know the
numbers started passing I started
talking with Cognito
and you know he said yo would you like
to go to e3 with us and I'm like I
didn't even know that was possible
so yeah so the big announcement is on
the channel my youtube channel is being
moved up to another level oh I'm gonna
be doing a lot of live from e3 reporting
I will be
I will be reporting live from the from
the show floor III 2019 yes I am also in
the compound with the iron Lords we're
gonna do an stuff live together it is
gonna be you know that the plane ticket
is paid the e3 ticket is paid the the
location is almost paid for in full now
I'm just trying to put some money away
for some spending money when I get down
there yeah this is this is I guess said
I have to you know first of all that's
one of the reasons why I wants to be on
episode 101 I have to congratulate you
on just magnificent achievement like I
said guys I've been listening to you for
the longest time and I actually got
turned off you know put on to you by my
brother who's in the chat Neil mental
ill men yes and you know what you know
when you say mr. Lee he gets a little
sore because no Lee kind of robbed him a
few times but you know a few you want to
talk about that yeah it's it's a it's a
big deal for me to be on this show to
announce that I am in fact going to be
at e3 a lot of circles I run and there
are a lot of guys that have been doing
this all 3 4 or 5 years longer than I
have have never been III so you guys met
you guys laid the groundwork for him you
kind of just said ok follow this path
boom and we'll get you the e3 fact RDM
is called III with boom and you know
your your your you know your direction
and your your your tutelage if you will
is gonna get me to my first e3 I'm four
I'm 40 I'll be 49 this year and this is
on the bucket list and thanks to the
iron Lords I will be there with them and
like I said there's gonna be a lot of
stuff coming for the channel that I've
never you know III happens and I go on I
do a podcast well this time I'm gonna
have a GoPro and I'll be doing it live
from the floor so yeah so thank you guys
for that and that's the big announcement
and let's hope that beer I can I can
just provide the co the quality content
that people come to know and love and
expect and that's why in me you know we
were joking when I first came on this
morning but your pregame you know I
wrote this is actually my sixth show
live show in five days and I wrote for
four shows and I gotta be honest with
you I've actually had insomnia for like
three days because
when you write that much you know each
show has to be different you know so
it's just a big shout out to you guys
and you know real quick just throw that
you got another super chat over there
give them a shout out shout out loaded
pixels aka Colbert let's give you some
context that is an original or yeah that
is a remote from the BX bar oh thank you
tonight I'll be click Wow also blank he
might not like I put his business up
also fellow x-men in blue we'll go in
there no store but uh no doubt your team
but he says yo your podcast is OK keep
up the good work happy 100-yard B tell
you right now that man in second has the
best Yoshimitsu eyeball man right there
Colonel the king of the Turner in the
upper cut deep yeah and the master one
of the Masters along with Lord sinister
one of the masses of pJAK where we use
the widow with the army fatigue hat with
the always repeat that was walking to
see you brother
this was oh yes yeah but I'll get to the
thing and I'll keep it short cuz I you
know I'm sorry I jumped in with the
announcement but you know here's the
thing I want to agree with King on on a
lot of things that he says you know if
if you or don't want to if you don't
want to accept it get out of the way or
get run over because that is what's
happening in the digital era you know
Phil Phil Dominus Spencer has said
numerous times that his goal has been to
reach 2 billion gamers and you're just
not gonna sell two billion Xboxes and
quite frankly he doesn't want to sell
two billion Xboxes and people just don't
get that the hardcore the guys in the
chat the guys on this panel especially
King will have the next five or $600
Xbox they're not gonna have a problem
selling it they came at this there's a
second one with no disk drive that's
gonna be probably three
under it that's gonna be cheaper than
the ps5 and that's gonna be moving like
crazy and you know why that is because
they're gonna have the games but in
regards to Nintendo you have to
understand something
Nintendo is in a position where both
both Microsoft needs Nintendo and
Nintendo needs Microsoft and you say
well boom you crazy we talking about
they're both doing good
well Sony is a hundred million seller we
know that already right but their
infrastructure is behind they are not
they're better than Nintendo but they're
not better than Microsoft so in Tendo
sees this listen we've been hearing
since last e3 that there's a new switch
coming do not be surprised that the
switch is gonna be as powerful as an
Xbox one maybe even though it may be
even an X and why why why would you want
to do that because you're gonna be able
to play all your Xbox games on your
switch on the go wow another this is
your the love today's and say like wow
shroom Kingdom man got to go but wanted
to say congrats on 100 you guys bring
great inside character and integrity to
the games will tune in again someone
thank you shrunk especially comment on
thank you brother
thank you so much continue move no no so
that's that's really about it I mean III
think that we're seeing a transition in
gaming and Microsoft and Phil Spencer
are at the forefront of change right
that's that's it that you know listen
it's gonna be it's they've been working
what let's look look we've heard this
since last e3 guys and you guys talked
about it we thought it was gonna be
something simple like banjo kazooie
going to smash and that's eventually
still gonna happen from sources that I
have talked to but this deal this dis
so-called you know love affair that's
been on the down-low the secret the
mistress that is that is now it's out
now it's out in the open so Microsoft
says yes that that that's my girl right
there and we doing it raw
[Music]
the iron Lords have helped myself and
the brat podcast become even bigger I
look forward to all the info you could
bring from e3 hope to be there next year
with you it's a movie his word treatment
for writers you know saying so again the
more the merrier please reach out to
dizzy myself after the show yes
definitely kiss movie if you want to do
you know the grass is greener over here
remember that I want you to go back I
want you to go back I told you I said I
said it's good happy I said fill out him
moving right so when Phil got up did he
say he wanted it all over the place
y'all thought it was a joke game y'all
thought it was the cookies right but
it's candy cuz it tastes good you gonna
give you a sweet tooth you're gonna love
it you can't get off of it
all right you can't eat it gonna kick in
you're gonna need it every day your
switch box
that's what new box is gonna be called
switch box all right so your switch box
is gonna have game pass on it all right
and every switch gonna call it that
alive now think about it this way I want
you to understand
right now this is forward-thinking you
can't have game pass on a switch without
having Xbox Live because a lot of those
games is tied with Xbox Live mm-hmm
so this is what I said before when they
fundamentally break down Xbox games with
gold roll that up into game pass because
they want game pass to be at the
forefront right and Xbox Live is baked
in to the game pass so when you purchase
one thing the PC cellphone switch
PlayStation wherever you game at with
game pass your login you'll be able to
talk to your peoples or your headset or
whatever and go to group chat and
everything is there a Nintendo need that
more than anything the company invade
your kingdom at e3 no you coming through
so you know all the vehicles will be
parked out there the Maseratis and stuff
I know and I know we're gonna do a three
so big it's so crazy this year God
willing um you know if we get there with
it is the plans for it is it's for y'all
guys if anybody got to work yeah work
that week tune in we're gonna bring it
back to you so any information on that
switch on on game pastor switch that
part it really didn't shock me I was
just waiting for the announcement what
shocked me was the Reggie retirement hmm
and then I looked at it as Reggie's a
real Duke mm-hmm all right now this is
this is all due respect to Reggie
Reddy's a real Duke nor dis Lander no is
no slander is no slander at all this is
absolutely zero sign the Reggie
understands he comes from a
where this is us versus them when Reggie
stepped on a stage like sovereign said
he said my name is Reggie I'm here to
kick butt and make games right that that
doesn't sound like a dude that's trying
to be buddies with you ha ha all right
that doesn't sound like a man that wants
to sit there and walk hand and hand down
the street I don't care what you've got
we got this so keep your behind over
there that sounds like I cut you at one
point that was yeah I forgot as a point
I wanted to make him reference to Reggie
that I actually forgot that I'm not
going to say leads to your theory but it
is something I have to be truthful which
is you know we forget that you know
Nintendo of America that's the
subsidiary right like Japanese you know
it's who he has to answer to answer
through and at the end of the day blood
being an international subsidiary head
is not easy because at the end of the
day as strong as he may feel about
something he's got to answer to the
heads and if the eds in Japan do not
want something they wanted to go a
specific way at the end of the day in
theory he's gonna have to bend the knee
mm-hmm whatever the bigger picture
because again they're an international
subsidiary so I'm just gonna put that so
that and if you look at the way and if
you look the way the Japanese market is
moved more towards marble moat more
towards like you know getting Nintendo
stuff on our mobile was with that was a
Japanese led initiative so that you know
just the thinking to me I think at the
top has changed like I said before he
may not it may not line up with what he
feels absolutely let me shout out yellow
shout out with the kickert nice Pulliam
with the $5 super chat Congrats on the
big 100 you guys making my Sunday Wow
thank you it's a 100 plus more stay
blessed stay blessed Kearney's thank you
so much actually that comment really
resonated with me thank you so much that
we make our Sunday we enjoy it man so I
can finish I'm gonna all right so all
right so doesn't it sound like this like
listen because I've been allowed around
a lot of people hmm
and I have a couple of guys um that
won't purchase another system because of
their loyalty to the system that they
have taught me I don't get the rationale
but I respect their decision right
because I'm a gamer so I'm gonna play
anywhere I'm nasty like that it doesn't
but they won't they don't care what God
wore did they don't care what spider-man
did they don't care it distant markedly
they don't care they've Microsoft to the
death and I got so many friends that all
right yeah so who's to say Reggie didn't
say we live in a world of shades of
colors everything is not black and white
so shade no color I can see a man of
Reggie's integrity saying not on my
watch you will not put that you will not
pin that on my back you can pin that on
Bowser and Bowser you tell you what the
new stuff gonna be but on my watch I
brought this to this situation I'm doing
I see y'all later cuz ya'll Wilin them
[Laughter]
what if what if Reggie was helping
orchestrate this before he was he has a
job he wants to make profits just you
know okay so all of this and to me I
don't see this as a move because of this
console war I let's put this into a
different perspective let's step back
for a second because the first thing
that we're gonna have to be looking at
is March 19th what does Google
doing right okay so Nintendo's not dumb
they know that they need to make certain
moves okay they don't have the current
infrastructure mmm okay who else is
rumored to be stepping into the fray
there's a big company that begins with
an A ends with an end
mm-hm they're also rumored to be okay
could I get a piece mm-hmm
so they have an infrastructure mm-hmm
google has an infrastructure mm-hmm and
we look at a you know where is gaming
movie so I think that this is less of a
move about what this current console or
this current console war is nothing we
for what is about to happen if these
other two do get involved let's also not
forget we're talking about Sony and you
know Japan and almost sony has this know
Sony's not king of Asia over there there
is a country that just lifted the gaming
market for them to be able to start
outsourcing in China there's a lot of
companies over there that they have the
infrastructures that Google and Amazon
have so they're also gonna be getting
into this fray once they're gonna start
being able to market outwards towards
other countries so the tool is doing
something smart like hey we need this we
need this in order for this to really
survive in this kind of climate because
you can gain mobile e on your phone
mm-hmm you know regardless of you know
the quality of the game that you're
putting out there so I think that this
is probably one of the smartest moves in
Nintendo could be making and I think
that is pretty smart for Microsoft as
well if you can put this stuff on there
like Xbox is not he's a delight with the
slag off oh he said Microsoft
surrendered we go we go get the Taser
but def comes up first yo this one of
our day one salute laws happy 100th
proud supporter shout-out to everyone in
the realm love y'all as friends can't
wait to get to meet you
is Microsoft so trendy
they been teeny but here's here's and
this is the problem when you're thinking
about modern console wars is you've got
to stop thinking about this plastic
versus plastic things box is not the
brand in that plastic box that is just
the way that you are playing your
current games on that system Xbox is
Xbox Live you got to start thinking of
it that way
mm-hmm so Waystation you've got to stop
thinking of it is this isn't the ps4
this isn't a ps5 it's the PlayStation
Network that's what you got certain
thinking about calling them catism so no
no I mean that that that's just that's
what it is is Nintendo has to pick what
is going to put them in a better
position mm-hmm right now Abby what's
better than Microsoft who already has
their hand in the pot and has an
infrastructure hmm servers there's no
service absolutely let's get solving ass
off man and news is breaking you know
it's it said it's a crazy time right now
right it's it's it's all this shift
going on and things that gamers are not
used to so what do you feel are you
surprised and you're not surprised like
where are you at with all this rumor
again it's all rumors right yeah you
know in reference to the Xbox game past
coming to the switch possibly IPS as
well
what were you at with this song okay so
first thing last thing on Reggie um
we'll know we'll have a better idea of
Reggie's motivations for leaving if his
retirement is true and he really does
stay retired was second if the hosel
because he says soldier boy
I bake I was done with I just had to
throw that IOU stupid you continue south
oh yeah so it ready does stay retired
right then it was just his time he
wanted to go it Reggie pops up somewhere
else in five months six months whatever
then yeah I'm inclined to believe that
it was a clashing of idea of ideologies
now in terms of the game past coming to
switch I told you so often
Thomas was first and the thing is and
I'm leaving and I'm probably even
getting a little bit of my prediction
correct and when it came to my
prediction that Microsoft wanted a
mobile platform or a true mobile
platform you know my thinking was that
it was gonna be a Microsoft branded one
as it turns out it's probably gonna be a
bento branded mobile platform but it
makes once once the announcement came
through that that live was going there
it was just a foregone conclusion the
game pass would be there at some point
guys are the truth and you're putting
the frauds in the bushes because God
wants us to be reading these so I mean
it was a foregone conclusion and this is
this is just the tip of the iceberg you
gotta see what Nintendo has been trying
to do in Japan you saw with resident 7
I'm streaming that over that you saw
with I believe it was a sea Odyssey as
well they would try to speak as locally
right so these are things that these are
ideas that have been percolating for
quite some time
this is something that they want to do
and not
domestically in Japan so like dizzy said
who was in the best position and who is
basically embedded with them already
Microsoft to be able to deliver on that
right and they will be certain and they
I know they specified a certain IP will
be probably offered as actual downloads
in the eShop or you being one of them
games that the switch can actually run
right and everything else that it can't
run next cloud I mean what all of this
says to me about X cloud is that all of
this confidence they have in this is not
hyperbole and as fun as you say that
because I got you says so for them to be
going this hard I wanted to put it on oh
wow Thank You Brady is he facing attic
like Phil's replace three hash tag oh
yeah big back oh my goodness man your
first was shot the native he's also one
of all he's on describe he's a lord
scribe yeah he's a good writer dude I
read some of his stuff writer yeah
article was tremendous he's also on
Lords of gaming dotnet proud brother in
the room thank you sir but yeah back to
your points off I agree because for them
to have that much confidence to be able
to put it honest they got to be really
sure about this tech at least of my
paper guys up I mean the moment you have
when the rumors come out and you start
having publications like Game Informer
start vetting these these these rumors
the it's essentially the truth already
at them yes some of these other sides
I'm not not discounting and you but
anybody's ability to put up good
information but like you know just
mainstream media gaming media sites when
you have a game informer talking about
something like this they're not gonna
talk about this unless they're pretty
damn sure it's a reality in some way
shape before yeah to me that I'm so
excited just to see what this X cloud
does and I said before I'm putting it
and putting the word out guys
make sure the IOP is in that beta please
need to get in that Bailey and getting
that better Lulu because the thing about
it is again 5g isn't quite there yet
we're not quite there yet but if they're
confident no King on samsung galaxy s 10
this year 5g is also another 5g phone
out right now in the test market I'm not
gonna promote them because I don't use
that brand but there's one out right now
as a folding phone in this 5g but the
capabilities is not there it's like when
they put fiber optics in your
neighborhood but fiber optics wasn't
really running yet but then we got right
up and you saw Verizon FiOS moving he
was like whoa what the hell that's
exactly what's gonna happen um so that
5g is coming I don't know if kognito is
gonna wait on galaxy I said cuz usually
when I'm going to Cali I usually have
the new phone um this year because I
have a galaxy or what is it called
galaxy infinite um and it's a package
that they offered before every new phone
to come out they send your survey which
phone do you want mm-hmm didn't want the
note and I said no to all the s tens
that they had available now you don't
have to give back in your phone you just
keep your phone and sell it whatever mom
so I want the 5g I was telling kognito
that and the specs on the 5g galaxy is
the s10 is ridiculous
so that leads to a sovereign's point
that that infrastructure is coming and
they they're not gonna launch their
phone and so it's absolutely ready I
agree I agree cut these off yes I said
like it's it's not quite there yet the
beginnings a bit of coming right and by
the time this next council generation
launches which we assuming is 2020 I
think it's it's just it's gonna be so
embedded in the public consciousness
every year we talk about those buzzwords
HDR whatever that comes out of tech 5g
is gonna be twenty twenties buzz one of
the big ones
um and the fact that gaming is gonna be
at the forefront of that and Microsoft
ready to launch X cloud again it's one
of those things that you don't believe
until you they cannot come out with this
and it be subpar so you have to believe
they it's really really something that
works hey that's what mate has me
excited about this and the fact of
nintendo's in bed with it forget it oh
you already know yo shout-out to the
Lord BG weapon will podcast in the
building for our one hundred man shout
out the weapon wheel man you guys been
killing it for a long time yeah bro I
mean look I'm like King you know all
this is no surprise to be man I mean
maybe the console warriors have died and
breathed their last breath know this new
exclusives but um it's just antiquated
fanboy logic is over you know I'm saying
like Phil told y'all last year every
device he's not lying you don't say this
is just an extension in a vision so I
would make assistant like soft on this
from the moment project has clouds
announced two billion gamers is the goal
just like boom said this is how you do
it TVs phones tablets PCs and hell no
less a switch to the equation he don't
give a damn if it's on your toaster
feelings your Samsung Refrigerator stop
shoutout slo-mo with the back slap
that's much right finally super Jack
Congrats 100 episode in website debut
all respect to you guys you continue
said he said also the division is the
greatest of all
bending me I'm which your division this
year division to I'm in there my brother
so me boom neo meant to all y'all my man
clowns Italian clowns I know he's
division heavy you know monkey you know
same damn check bear hat oh yeah big
crazy
Andy Mac we was gonna daily come you saw
the clam stuff they put alright let me
get it to the time but uh yeah but
that's how you do it man so um I
personally saw y'all I can't wait to use
my the stream any and and in the the
Sony fans that are really holding on to
hope that you know that they're
somebody's gonna be in that walled off
garden
forward it's not happening so I told you
is not happening yeah from already said
it
so what's funny is the same root of
wiggling is gonna happen for a lot of
people who up again antiquary
fanboy logic those days are over this is
business y'all and again a so anyway
like I said I can't wait to get my mice
which stream on my game pass games yeah
oh yeah we know switch don't have the
power to hand without on the go and what
if what if what if the onslaught of
Google and Amazon is forcing the major
three to work together half to survive
Google is a major player would you say
dizzy I heard you torpor and I said I
wouldn't be surprised you know that's
actually another point that I would I
would actually point out um cuz I just
can't see Sony wanting to work with one
of the the companies over there in China
you know this gives their infrastructure
can be I mean but at the same time I
wouldn't be surprised if you start to
see the same thing also happen you know
with Sony with one of the others I I can
see them linking up with Google I could
see them winking up with Amazon you know
you know kind of kicking back you know
also looking at you know Microsoft
whenever they were buying a lot of
studios and everybody's a go they're
doing it because you know they're
getting kicked in the ground by Sony and
Nintendo no underlying these studios
because they don't want Google and
Amazon to get a hold of them first they
already took Twisted Pixel from them
yeah you know they weren't though first
ones they were working on a believe it
was Twisted Pixel that was working on a
wasn't killer HD and got by Amazon so to
shut out the one bad mother of the name
super check you guys are excellent if
you aren't mainstream yet you need to be
thank you brother that means a lot chop
the Philly
II grew that's why did he'd be on the
last word a lot I was saying it won't be
any bother
he said plastic loyalty is stupid
Internet of branding is to be global
if you don't accept that might as well
stop gaming laugh-out-loud Xbox brand
trying to be global Jean and dropping
the knowledge continue dizzy now that I
mean that's just you know kind of like
weird guys like there's a lot of moves
that are being played you know you gotta
you got to play your moves properly on
the chess board to know what your next
move is gonna be and I think that
Nintendo's doing it I think you know
Microsoft's doing it I think Sony's just
trying to figure out you know what way
they need to you know move theirs and do
they stay by themselves and they do and
do they press what the the PlayStation
Network with one of them I you know what
I would say dizzy and I'm gonna say this
to that point that I don't believe Sony
would evil partner with Google or Amazon
and any other streaming company for this
one fact they were the other dude number
there was a sidechick for Nintendo and
in that process they realized when you
give something power what happens and
Nintendo games Sony Power had Nintendo
worked with Sony that wouldn't happen
but they decided to shun them and go
with Philips and then what happened they
gave him power to gave him like this
they gave him that Avenue in they're not
gonna give anybody any info cuz it was
built up to the point they showed them
they gave them the roadmap on how to
build them how to get in they're not
gonna do that to Google or Amazon Google
and Amazon or global icons that will
destroy they will eat and destroy oh he
said he thinks Sony was pairing with
Verizon for game streaming that might
happen but I honestly think and this is
my humble opinion right and it means
nothing
all right but this is my humble opinion
that these three understand that
sometimes you must work together with a
cop against a comedy you don't this
sounds like literally this sounds like
an episode of Game of Thrones the White
Walkers you know my cure sauce in this
kingdom so he's kind of like the
latticed is a little
resisted it right dizzy they don't want
to join just yet they don't you know
they want to see what happen but already
you don't say you already got you know
the Khaleesi how people that's last say
that's the $10 you know say buy yourself
whatever you got that as Jon Snow
you're pretty working together just no
Achilles he's already worried yet they
know what must be done for the White
Walkers thing for us his game is this I
don't care what you guys say right and
I'm talking to the outside guys when
Microsoft for Nintendo battles on when
Sony and Microsoft and Sony Nintendo
they battle that's in fighting that's in
the yard you have a fault on your
neighborhood on your block in your
project you fought but if people from
the other project came to your project
you band together to beat them back yes
right so you beat them back and then
y'all get back to the infighting it
doesn't matter if a trait infiltrate
your structure alright y'all are one
unit yeah my fight this is the console
war right and this is it right here
yeah I mean I want to finish it real
quick listen I'm exciting like I said I
really want to get my string up you know
get my switch play these Xbox game class
I guess doc come on fine now get some
questioning Sophos like I'm curious how
the Xbox Live integrations gonna be
right the the achievements will party
chat will it be a full feature set
experience cuz if that's the case whoa
ain't no need for an xbox portable at
that point cuz no at that point anything
there's Xbox for a lady I think we'll
have four spot live integration any any
any sort of Xbox property anything that
comes to the cloud through new game pass
to me is is full Xbox Live integration
yeah if you have integration
achievements party chat all that stuff
and let's be real like switch has the
perfect form factor right got both your
shift buttons you got you know I'm
saying a d-pad you know the whole Ann
laws both clicking in all the weaknesses
of the Vita that didn't have all the
extra functionality where they had to
substitute put a touchpad under the
bottom and all this other stuff switch
has full function
to play the games they just didn't have
the power you know I'm saying too late
again so but to me out of all this was
more interested in these rumors that
we're hearing about margin
self-published games you know I'm saying
like a re a cuphead possibly coming down
as debt download or retail so even the
rumors we hear in scalebound possibly
being reborn with platinum games on a
switch so I'm shut up dude shut up I
wanna shout a whole blah he's got a
great video right now virtually
gallantly talking about that and even
though Microsoft owns the assets we know
that the trademark for scalebound I
think it was um it was abandoned about
two years ago oh it wouldn't be it
wouldn't surprise me with this cozy
relationship that Nintendo and Microsoft
have especially since minecraft you know
I'm saying integration you know I'm
saying that they they might be working a
lot of like okay you do this for me I do
this for you kind of a me you don't say
and the other thing that Microsoft
unveiled at GDC cross-play that SDK
right so for this so then each end of
already letting you know we willing to
play with us like we really do to cross
cross play for at night rock and all
that stuff and I already wrote an
article in Tendo was on it cuz their
last and switch has K it's supported
cross play voice its action through
vivix in and I put this in a text
section it's on Lords a gaming dotnet
plug plug yeah yeah what is out here
right not informative article check that
out you know I'm saying this at the end
of day I think this just could be a
defining shift in gaming all these
rumors proved to be true this is a power
ship I saw I'll let you finish it you
want to say something good no no I mean
I'm just gonna echo what you said it's
it's for the first time in forever
really that you see Nintendo being open
to this amount of change yes and being
willing to step out of the walled garden
and not necessarily you have Nintendo
like solutions for things right I mean
when the Swiss launch day everything
around us which is still very much
Nintendo life and they heard it from us
about things that we expected that we
expect out of the big
three that they weren't giving us right
all the end for all the online
infrastructure stuff just general
Nintendo stuff that we you would call
them grandpa Nintendo for and I think
they've taken that to heart and they've
realized look we need to be at least in
terms of this I don't think they're ever
gonna be in that power narrative with
with Playstation and with Xbox mm-hmm I
think in at least in terms of
functionality in terms of network in
terms of infrastructure they realize
they cannot be behind in that in that
arena they just can yeah III agree man I
think this is this is very powerful
times I'll let boom end it off it will
move off that arm you know in a sense
that I agree with the boom that like you
know all that antiquated way of looking
at things from a console sports
perspective like my team versus your
team yeah you know I'm saying that's
over and I feel sorry for a lot of
people you know because at the end of
the day if you feel that strongly you
know that you know this is it's over you
know
surrender or whatever the terminology is
don't like they don't care if you go say
you know what Xbox is done as a brand
I'm getting the PC you know what they
said go over there get there cuz you
gonna still give us that bread over yeah
it was bread bread over there and switch
you steal whatever you go and you play
that game that you like that you so
upset that it's not on the Microsoft
console they are still getting your
money so you know you gotta reach out to
Lorraine he got a great great video if
you really don't buy nothing Microsoft
let's see whereas them yeah
because if you cuz it's going to be
everywhere when you put up with T they
already talked about the TVs the tablets
all that so you can't avoid it you're
going to have to bend to me no matter
how you slice it if you know you are a
true fan boy yeah it's real great you're
gonna be in your you're really you're
gonna have a tough time beautiful you
know I just wanted I want to close this
up because I want to just kind of give a
big shout-out to slow-mo backslap who
said you know and I bet I said this on
crossfire and I got kind of booed a
little bit um but that's okay because I
could take the cheese and the booze
because I think they're just saying boom
yes that's ok that's an ila at the M
form so when disabled of it in their
form so I don't feel bad um you know the
the biggest talk of the town with Xbox
Live over the last I don't know 5 6 7 8
10 years is that people want that
paywall torn down yes and I called it on
crossfire I'm a quote on the Lord's
podcast right now III 2019 which I will
be sitting in that room when they do it
he's gonna say Phil diamond is gonna say
as of today Xbox Live is no longer a
payable thing it's part of Microsoft but
how they gonna do that 2 billion game is
playing game paths and paying $10 a
month that's how they're gonna subsidize
all of that and all those games going to
the Nintendo switch and wherever else
and listen I know I was talking about
the ask eventually go to Sony Sony is so
stubborn and because they spent three I
mean 300 million dollars on Gaikai to
get that that trash that they have oh
yeah it hasn't probably download but the
bottom line is this I think Sony's less
stubborn that they let on and and and I
say this but specifically by short
ladies last interview and it is yes yes
he was very talkative you're right the
only thing I wonder is right there may
they're talking the this game that
they're gonna be there in bed with all
of this services based stuff at all of
it my only question is because I don't
think they didn't they didn't not read
the tea leaves right and not dump they
knew what was coming the question is how
how much they this decided to focus on
it back when when it was gonna be a
factor now right if they if they sort of
put it off to the side and they just
said yeah it's coming but we're gonna do
our own thing then they might find
themselves in a very tight spot now
right so that's my worried that they
knew it was coming they knew it was
coming the question is how much stock
that they put in it early on say this
would all do some therapy
filss it differs an old boy got the memo
they pulled him in office the same way
they pull Reggie in the office he said
look here look here
these dudes over here they doing this
I'm in a sanitarium we're gonna go on
this direction and he said well I don't
wanna retire so he says we give you a
lateral movement I'm gonna put you up
this way you go that way but we're gonna
pull us out to do it in and he's
download the smoke so I didn't fall
under your watch and he said he said
cool cool I'll take it that way he said
but listen when you go out there and you
speak to the public you're gonna let
them know and we're trying to put
PlayStation everywhere but but didn't
Phil just yeah yeah I feel sad that and
um Phil gave us the call and we're gonna
build the thing together
well I want you to go out there and I
want you to spread the word that
PlayStation was trying to get on every
device it's not just a box all right
questions I have for the most immediate
things like okay so if you have a xbox
live being a platform what do we think
about like the possibility of
achievements 4010 doe games like let's
say you're playing it on the switch
maybe achievements on games comfort
obviously ones backwards and maybe a
little bit more difficult to control
what's the possibility of that I think
that probably for me probably one of my
most reluctant this man right let me
tell you how something about cat daddy
man like I am so humbled not forget the
money but I just love his presence in
our chat
yes entertaining no honey he's always
appreciative for that whether $100 super
Chad driving from Cali to Atlanta every
week means I'd miss out a lot but one
thing is content IOP you guys are a
positive light and what's been a toxic
community this generation keep up the
great work and happy
100 shoutout to you to watch your old yo
daddy like a patreon supporter just been
there from from day one man day one you
know my greatest memory of Quetta I got
a beat is that what he just you don't
hear him when the whip and he had his
whip iced out with every color I LP
shirt see but I knew it was happening
because he hit me and then that's when I
was doing the shipping and all that here
gonna damn me said what he needed and I
send it to him and when he post a
picture
I knew he was getting them now I did I
know that he was gonna lay it on wit
like that man reps us in like I said we
those are the eggs that we will when I'm
tired when we late you know I'm saying
like when we up late thinking the
concepts and stuff like that those are
the motivation I can't let these people
down these are the people who support it
the most man thank you brother really
means a lot wow wow wow you know they're
[Laughter]
busy to your point you know it is gonna
be interesting how that integration gold
finale you know my gut proud of me says
that everything any game that's within
the game class app and then the
infrastructure
Elfi of the cloud will probably have
that achievement system I know it's
gonna go outside that but if they're
looking to bring stuff like Ori and
cuphead as separate downloadable games
interesting because technically those
are for outside of the apps we went by
or in the store so will that have the
functionality also will it be a curated
xbox game pass list because there are
some titles already like rocket leagues
on game pass right and you know there's
titles that switch already has so maybe
the antennae says hey you know it's like
curating like specific to the era that
did that make sense
interesting man to see how this thing
goes but look we got a lot of [ __ ] we
could talk about all day King got a bomb
topic right now so I want to get out or
a dick baby you got some power a little
bit
he's in the chat if you betta fatties
that yo you gotta get in here man we got
to speak to the wastelands of us oh
gotta mark his brother got a mighty Mike
is bangin
oh yeah you know he banging somebody
Mike is back but Mike is literally
banging like literally banging maybe
it's dead
we'll figure it out we'll figure it out
but hopefully I could get in here man
cuz miss ya didn't get any uses 100 so
he compounds with us
but anyway Lord King we got some
scholarly knows he's going oh now we
hear in these rumors first of all first
and foremost shout-out to burger right
now Bret yo Scarlett gonna be a d3
listen I man I told y'all last year Mike
Ibarra from his own mouth who told me
don't miss next year is gonna be epic
right yeah we've heard that probably 20
minutes 25 minutes later after that I'm
talking to Phil I'm name-dropping like
the game so what I'm talking to Phil ha
ha um um Phil Dominus
Dominus told me yo um don't miss next
year it's gonna be epic same words two
different people and then I'm starting
to see the leaks so the white paper is
out let me get the white paper because
I'm gonna be accurate when I tell you
this Oh
y'all don't have a seat as usually you
catch me freestyling off the top now
right now I'm giving you the white
papers they're white papers here two
white papers right so we have the
Lockhart Xbox Lockhart specs it's a CPU
a COS 16 Xen threads tuned right then
you have this GPU that's a custom Navi
for Plus teraflops right and then you
have the RAM that 12 gigs of DDR 6
memory and a storage drive is a one
terabit plus
gigabyte of SDS SSD drive right now
that's crazy because the solid state
hard drive now listen to this I want you
to understand this part I got it from an
exec that works at Microsoft now I can't
out him because he's my source but this
is a confirmed sauce that they said
everything going forward with that new
Microsoft Surface mm-hmm that has the
SSD drive inside every Microsoft product
after that will have a solid state hard
drive in it
yeah bout time because we need them fast
boot times brother but he explained to
me he has an S and we were loading into
worlds playing destiny and I'm like oh
you stole you wanted ahead of me how are
you downstairs
what are you doing what you talking
about flying I got ass I mean I gotta
act you got ass right so my latest came
out he said I replaced it with
Microsoft's recommendation state hard
drive oh yeah huge difference huge and I
I swear by this so now this is why I
believe these papers is right right now
next is the Xbox anaconda specs a custom
8 cores 16 Xen threads to write like
mods gaming talk about ridiculous custom
night mods mods does it on a level that
I can't even get close with mods I'm
doing it from here you do it from real
knowledge um custom Navi 12 teraflops 16
RAM 16 gigabytes of ddr3 storage 1
terabyte and one gigabyte of solid-state
hard drive alright I bring this to the
table let's go what do you all believe
in these specs do you believe these
specs to be true giving all the
circumstantial evidence that we have in
front of us I'm talking above here when
I say that as a former police officer
when you have facts laid out in front of
you because you don't do it in isolation
you deal with evidence facts in front of
you and you make a determinate
based off of these things mm-hmm what do
you think sir well look the proof is in
the paper right you know what I'm saying
if the gun is by with on the crime scene
and the fingerprints from the man that
you have in custody are there then he is
going to jail that is that simple and
you know what listen let me say
something
um I have to throw this in UK shout-out
to kognito who told me boom you came at
the right time for e3 2019 because it's
gonna be your life when we get to
California and I'm guy goosebumps from
my toes to the top of my Mohawk right
here okay because I'm an Xbox dude
through and through I know I guess I
have no connections other than you guys
so I'm gonna hope that I can get myself
into of course hey like I said as fan
fest is great but I want the conference
thank you mean that that's the main goal
because I want to be there when Phil
comes I'm gonna be that guy yelling yeah
killer instinct too or something like
that that's gonna be me but now these
these numbers you know first of all
people have to understand something you
know you if you're a tech head and
you're you're in suspects you're gonna
be wait a second I don't understand the
the first one that's supposed to be the
cheapest system how is it gonna be more
powerful it's because of the GPU okay
it's gonna run better than that it's
gonna be an EXO if you have an X now you
don't wanna you don't want to get that
you know you don't wanna spend the money
I hear ya it's gonna run great but if
you want the you know the second system
which is everyone in this panel everyone
this Chad's gonna be running out to buy
that 500 or $600 experience the premium
King experience you're gonna be playing
games
in a way ain't no it's funny you know we
talked about social media guys right and
we talked about you know a lot of the
Sony crowd that I know there's some good
people's in Sony
all right then the plenty of them but
you have the extremists that just make
it really difficult to try and throw out
a lot
conversation it is a fact that the
playstation 5 is not going to be as
powerful as the Anaconda that is fact
folks okay if they already said it's 8
to 12 terabytes well we know what to
tell what the anacondas gonna run and
and in the circles that I'm talking
about that of the trove make is well
power don't really matter it's the games
well they're gonna have that to listen
Phil Spencer came in in 2017 and he
turned this ship and did a 180 and it is
gonna be rolling so strong to e3 2019
through 2020 if you're not on board
you're gonna drowned so get it you get
so fun Xbox you know and just get on
board and you know what stop with the
plastic nonsense man just support all
three consoles so you can just play
every game
absolutely boom job is some knowledge
may let me get solving here man then
we'll get you feel man like you we see
in these leagues going down between
anaconda and Lockhart we hear in
speculation of it you and Bill that III
and then there's another more bomb that
we forgetting man yeah so here
halo Infinite is supposed to launch with
Scarlett
so what bring this to you man like what
do you think about all this bro
alright so first off in terms of the
specs right the Lockhart an anaconda
specs honestly feel like the Lockhart
specs are a little low the way I see it
like I would like the Lockhart to be on
paper more powerful than an X and then
I'll break that down when I got an icon
to be exponentially more powerful than
that right that's what I would like to
see so it just seems like the Lockhart
specs are a little bit low what's
interesting though obviously we don't
know the speed of each of these eight
cores right so that's gonna be key to
how how fast the system can run um the
fact that they're talking about uh nvme
SSDs is great because nvm YZ are
specifically designed to run faster
it's just it's just it's a different set
of operations and specifically made for
SSDs and that's why they run faster so
it's it's cool that they're looking to
integrate that into that um so that's
that's my only thing with that I think
anaconda specs are great I would like to
have even seen it even more terrified
big joke about the anaconda for you you
were there but the 16 gigs of DDR 6 is
big that's more than enough
Lockhart's solve yeah
and again the lockhart again it is
something that it's speculated that
that's gonna be this nono diskless it's
gonna be the one that they push as sort
of the streaming console right and the
downloadable console so um but I still
think it should be more powerful but
that's it um I'm I'm excited to see what
this stuff is um now the other thing in
terms of Halo Infinite yeah I I
absolutely see it as being a launch site
or you know what you're trying to
reinvigorate people love of the Xbox
brand how do you do that well you
emulate one of its finest moments and
for me the Xbox brand really began to
take hold right right from the jump when
people came on said what the hell is
that halo thing everybody's talking
about what the hell is that halo and to
me they have not launched a console with
a halo since the OG xbox yes sir and
that to me halo defined Xbox moving
forward um obviously things have changed
but I think if you want to reinvigorate
that name that brand you wants with a
Halo game ro let me I got a break order
cuz you saw coming out of it let's again
we got to reiterate all rumors
speculation for now right we go
reiterate but if all this is to be
believed this is how you take advantage
of your competitor now speak on it bro
if you first of all a lie with Nintendo
to extend you use a bass with a bass
drop before regarding your next
generation hardware first to captivate
that you
III mindshare a new cycle right a full
year I had a release which by the way
has proven successful for them because
they did this with disk or pew and
everybody thought it was a mistake don't
in Vail
how can you in Vail two systems in one
conference remember that was the talk
see we've got full proof to MPD shot the
mac piscatella you know we've had him on
the show before in the room that the
Scorpio did quite well from a revenue
standpoint so this would be a Power Move
now as for the hallway solve I feel you
all right here's a they know I'm I'm on
an opposite side with you on Lockhart
Lockhart really impressed me
for this reason only I love that the CPU
is the same as anaconda yep not huge we
got something definitely do right but if
we if we believe what boom is saying
right imagine let's say Lockhart is $200
and it's as powerful as the bass ps5
mm-hmm that's crazy
do that straight that's a that the zone
that's a Sony move dudette is that is
taking a page right out of the ps4
launch price and I'm so excited
so listen Lockhart impress be like
suggest from the CPO compatibility
standpoint that's huge to me so
basically the way I'm looking at it's
all is you're telling me Lockhart is
basically this next generation beefy
1080 60 machine but it's got the CPU so
for those to me I think of Lockhart for
addict right but that's the thing how
who's the main consumer we're not
thinking we're not thinking about the
Anaconda is the boutique system right
the main consumer is the attic that
Lockhart is where I gotta stop disparage
it's what is addict in the sense that he
doesn't care about you soon as I finish
all those people now looking to do that
job right you can save some bread yeah
that's a did you got an economist the
big boy yeah you got crazy more DRAM all
that good stuff you know and at twelve
teraflops which is basically the bushes
explaining how it's beneficial for him
lay down just take it about what me and
adequate here he would say to say no you
know what I don't believe that I
honestly believe in every man they
strive for the upper excellent he will
have enough time to get the upper
echelon because those 4k TVs will be at
a price where he's able to do that he'd
probably have a bundle they're probably
gonna do some silly thing like you can
just get this and get that and just
finance that and just like they was
doing with tax at Ruby obviously the
highest like a slider it's one of those
things like I said the big boy you don't
say twelve teraflops damn Nate listen
anacondas damn they double the tariff
flocks of X so that's crazy when I to
remember be richer I got a confession no
in the realm that twelve teraflops man
that's when I cheat right back oh he's
seeing bring my behind right back
because so folks good to see
we'll be late you know say now the only
thing that's interesting to me though is
the future of the Xbox one X cuz it's in
an interesting spot right just Cordova
we had him on the show he said X might
be in the bushes but here's the thing no
like stop it still has more teraflops
than the Lockhart the CPU did you yeah
so I'm you and and you're talking about
Navi cores - right yeah yeah yeah that's
true we got that so it you know it's in
a weird spot but I feel I'm working like
I feel them a little overclocked Jaguar
cause the focus on to me they need to
make that Lockhart as powerful as they
possibly can as at the best price point
they can and that's that's gonna be the
sticking point but what what if that's
the sweet spot what if like it's boom
saying like that's the 400 sweet spot
and let's just say theater we don't know
what ps5 stance I'm not gonna try to see
but let's just say it's equivalent to a
lot car or maybe a little bit like say
if you get in on at that level right for
an eye level right there and then you
got for 500 internal or whatever it is
that an economy is going to be to jump
in the game and I'm saying it still BS
but at some point the ex Scott has to
drop in price we would assume that right
yeah because you can still get we use I
have a fond of those like I'm maybe not
right maybe the components inside the
system has forced them to move over to
some different type of architecture that
they can't afford to drop the price down
on this and they just phase that out the
Forte's easy don't flip flop LOCOG you
know we need to stick together I'm still
getting Xbox brother
I'm getting an anaconda and I'm gonna be
over there I'm just letting you know
imma be over there you know all I'm
saying is that I'm not you can't
undermine the importance of where
Lockhart's it's because once again with
we're just talking if we're talking
about anaconda we're talking in an echo
chamber that that is not that is not
mover right you know I mean so that that
Lockhart has to be situated in a place
where it's gonna move right and
therefore if they can if they can pull
it at four I think it's gonna be yeah I
agree I think they're gonna dig they're
gonna make people want to buy this
console and jump into the next
generation again it's it's yeah because
you know again it did the parts are
gonna be cheaper listen look look this
is this is this is a tactical assault
that's gonna happen in the next
generation and Phil Spencer is the
general you know pushing you know the
the tanks across the top of the map
saying this is what how we gonna take
over when he still Dominus that's when I
was all in because y'all none of y'all
acknowledged that name I'm not calling
anybody down think about it in that
fashion because the way he's moving like
bomb said easy listen he's playing
Stratego listen man this do right now
yo the way he is moving the parts it's
the gear down the lay down if he comes
in at $300 we all know that the
PlayStation 5 base spec does the system
is going to be more powerful than the
weaker um Lockhart right we know that so
alright the Lockhart on get in there it
has some of the forms of the Anaconda
anaconda gonna be on oh you talking to
my little brother man was good bro
right you with the big head come in
right
so I so for those dudes like when you go
to a car dealership you got a car
dealership they have a one series BMW
and they have a 7 series BMW mm-hmm they
both BMW brands right so BMW brand sells
to one type of customer but there's
seven series do is it different kind of
do we don't be on there anaconda 7
series stuff run but a lot of people
will get that 300 listen a hundred
dollars if that playstation file come
$100 more they at the same position
Microsoft was in yes sir
very very well said and that's where the
master strategist has pushed his chips
in the middle of the table and say llamo
bruh it'll be interested see where I
shot a semi Prescott he feels that Conor
will be in the middle
he says he's buying multiple anacondas
in one ps5 that I have too many 4k OLED
to be gaming on subpar consoles the ex
getting traded in and Lockhart is not an
option to the halo thing and I'll give
it to this is that on you know look all
tech stuff out the way if halo Infinite
is a launch title it's over
oh boy that's how you establish it's a
new day's sad this sinister he's like
that's how you put your edit card to
meet or the table of God I gotta be
honest with you I was gonna say
something to that effect because this is
P Gina you know normally boom don't be
making nasty references Bible was coming
down but it's funny kognito cuz you know
we're talking about how in all jocks
aside we're talking about how you know
halo is rumor to be a launch out just
think about this for a second
no no everyone everyone knows I have not
made the announcement I think it's
coming this year just imagine these
three games as launch titles for for the
next Xbox in 2020 you get your halo you
get your new fable and you get your
Forza Motorsport 8 and then then you
turn around you throw in some double a's
on top of that you know you get obsidian
in there you get in exile in there you
know we're hearing that we may see Ninja
Theory this year you know rare was
working on a second title you know the
gears guys are working on a pot you know
rumor to be um a perfect dark reboot
maybe that's a launch title dude there
that the chips like I said just just
just imagine Phil he's got on that big
big jacket he's got the big cigar he's
holding it and in one hand he's holding
of cigar on the other hand is pushing
those chips onto the map and he's
surrounded Sony he said we got we got a
Nintendo over here we got filled Dominus
is not taking prisoners he says you know
what when we're surrounded firing squad
leave no one left alive that would be
huge you know listen King me you add
that mark self-preservation
now I don't know about you King but when
I saw the hail infinity trailer I was
happy to be wrong I never got the
feeling that that was coming for this
generation you know they like I always
if I'm not gonna say what it was Friday
night I just felt like this is kind of
concept II you don't say you 100% right
there that right there was a concept art
put this together let them know that
bass know we're working on it but I
never got the sense that the Xbox when X
was getting that right now later this
year so make no mistake though a lot of
pressure on 343 you know saying after
Halo 5 you know I'm saying they had the
best multiplayer no doubt but we all
kinda agree the story wasn't necessarily
executed but dogmeat oh no told me
doesn't you you just said there's a lot
of pressure on 3 for 3 right flash of
shout out the Barney I took a picture of
Bonnie she is a wonder
first unplug plug all right that's right
I'm gonna front I love women in gaming
and I love women execs in gaming showing
that women can reach the highest level
without that's right that's what she'll
but that you said that 343 has a lot of
pressure they had a lot of pressure on
ones bungee laugh yeah they dealt with
that pressure they dealt with the
scrutiny Oh with the halo remixes and
all they've dealt with a whole bunch of
onboard scrutiny and I think they've
come out with flying colors I think this
halo infinite and it's the start of
their own shoes and antics yes yes ooh
engine new engine and I just love the
fact they get a chance to work we're
more powerful hardware they're not going
to be limited you don't say and have to
stick kind of like to an older Bungie
formula they can do them this exciting
times y'all it's exciting to talk dizzy
I know I've been talking for a long time
after they're put on this man what do
you feel real quickly I know we got a
lot of show but a real quickly wrap him
up always I'll make mine nice and short
I'm gonna take a line from Marshawn
Lynch
I'm only here so I don't get fired
you'll be fine so like everything that
y'all have said fantastic let me just
throw this on top of it and everything
because we're talking about you know
another thing that comes into gaming we
start looking at their party market
deals we talk about rumors of course
there's the the fanatical rumor right
now oh well bungees now a new mistress
and you know and obviously they're
little little dabs put on by you know
Phil and company you know towards Bungie
but also recently rumors of call to duty
marketing going back to Microsoft that's
another thing you know to put out there
and let's you know these companies they
are seeing the machines right now that
shouldn't tell you a little bit of what
they're looking at so I think it I think
it's in a good position no doubt no
doubt man exciting exciting times man a
lot of information again all rumors or
speculation but at the same time you
know
could be some truth here so we'll see
how it plays out man if that's the case
boom we could we could be in for one
hell of a new truth man I can't wait
absolutely Lord saw of last topic of the
day don't be be nice be nice I like Mike
we got to keep it true at the rep let's
go man
all right so um I have a kind of a
two-parter here so the first part I want
to talk about is uh so this past week
Mike Ibarra made some comments on
Twitter about about anthem and
specifically reviews about anthem how he
felt some people and the exact word that
he used was whining about specific
things in the game um and he sort of he
cited a he's he cited he indicated that
there was a specific review he had seen
that had sort of kind of sighted certain
things but they they made it clear like
they didn't understand the game they
didn't know how to do everything in the
game and he made a comment indicating
that it was it was sort of embarrassing
that someone would actually review a
game without actually you know having
played it or having a deeper knowledge
of the game playing games mechanics
right and so obviously these these
comments had a reaction on Twitter as
they always do um so I want to know what
you guys feel about what he said should
he have said it should not have said it
said he put it another way and how do
you feel about how people reacted to it
and it's good good that boom is here
because uh one of the first people
actually that answered in in the in Mike
Ibarra sort of uh timeline was actually
a brother near mental that he kind of
reacts he said listen man like people
just want a functional game like people
wanted in this game that you know that
they should not have to be sort of have
to hold back on how they feel about it
when there's certain things that are
fundamentally sort of broken about this
experience so I just want know what you
guys feel about the comments how they
how people reacted to them that stuff
and that's that's part one let let a
boom go and I got a lot to say on this
and I
okay I have history here but uh i'ma let
boom go first but I want to go after
bull okay wait wait you said you got a
lot do I would say okay
iris a sovereign would the top is good
table so sovereign goes last
okay so we move solvent to the back all
right dizzy only here for the check
[Laughter]
don't think we pay people okay so then
yes absolutely let card me to go first
on like me to do I listen okay
this is a very tough one for me because
um obviously you know I'm saying you
guys know what my key bar is a good
friend to the round yeah I met him a
bunch of times
various events actually game together
with my you know me so full disclosure I
did not initially want to talk about
this situation solve but it's the round
table so we got it we got to keep it
true we got to keep it true so let me
give you guys some backstory first like
what those who don't know and I don't
think Mike would be upset with me
revealing this part is that he is truly
a hardcore gamer right yeah no mistake
this is the Luna shooter king destiny
anthem division pub G apex Mike gets
busy he probably gave more than a lot of
yog games I'm gonna keep it a thousand
I'm naughty there's no sugar Kony that's
just what it is from what I see
am i I you know I mean so give you a
case in point in destiny when they
nerfed the rhetorics claim or you know
destiny to it's one of the longest and
hardest PvP crucible guns to get Lord
Mike was tight he be tweeted Bungie
direct like oh you making it easy for
these dude like that's just who he is
that just says a testament to how
passionate he is and then I know for a
fact he's very passionate about yet you
know say plays old
half of my destiny clan which is in it
they're all playing anthem now I'm
saying that's just what it is so I guess
he was upset about the review of not
knowing and lacking of knowledge at his
basic combo I get it you know sir I
completely get he's not technically
wrong right but at the same time as the
VP for Xbox you know I'm saying you make
a public statement it could kind of come
off wrong and it it connects even though
that may not be his intention it may
come off like a direct attack that like
journalists in general and I do feel bad
for the kid like oh man oh I think I
just Gordon he's a little saddened by
his comments also so Mike's next week's
you want to clean it up you know pretty
much one want to say that you know he
looks at multiple review sources as a
whole that I agree with you know Sam and
most people make you know an informed
decision I get it
Mowen thing is just the timing of what
he said even though he technically was
not wrong it just comes off bad because
the mass is gonna say oh you only keep
it for that game cuz Anton and Microsoft
got the exclusive marketing but they go
they go come at you Mike for that you
know I'm saying at the same time they
gonna say yo you ain't keep that same
energy with the crackdown review rules
so look Mike's go my duel with garlic I
think he knows better next time and on
Twitter Mike please press s because
could at the end of the day King you
listen here good dude that's my god it's
just that you know when you you feel it
if you if he says it is gonna get
twisted yes first well here's the thing
let me just say this there's there is
something that that has been lost in the
last 10 years is called journalistic
integrity it's also something called
journalistic responsibility and if you
guys now you haven't already invited me
to write on your site which I'm gonna do
alright
that's gonna be the first site that I
write on is gonna be your site thank you
okay I am going to hold myself to the
highest possible standard that I could
possibly hold myself because my name is
going at the end of that article okay
the
problem with this participation trophy
generation that we are living in is they
just want to write something and throw
it out there to get their name out there
and no responsibility to what they're
right let me let me just say this okay
you cannot go and drop a review if you
don't even know how to do that goddamn
super I am sorry that isn't that is
unacceptable behavior for a gamer and
that's even worse so for a journalist
you cannot turn around and listen if you
play a game for 30 hours and and you're
reviewing this game and you beat the
game and you know you've done everything
and there's something you don't like
that you can justify what you're saying
but you be like for instance and I'm not
calling him out but a perfect example
Jeff Gerstmann of Giant Bomb did the
same thing the guy is playing the game
first of all he don't like any game ever
if you ever listened to that that guy
hates everything I don't even know how
he's in the business and I said it I
said it on crossfire and I'll say I
don't know his credential should be
removed and stamped on ineffective for
the gaming space collective opinion Lord
booster game yeah listen I used to be a
giant giant pond kind of a dude I
listened to both of them and I and I've
listened to them for years I don't
listen to them anymore because he you
know every game he touches he hates this
dad another thing but my whole point is
that getting back to this reviewer you
know you can't put a review that
accompanies spent built millions and
millions of dollars on and and and and
half-foot it man I'm sorry that that's
unacceptable
and this and you know what what's a
shame it has become acceptable in this
generation of the participation trophy
just get out there do the best you can
and if you if you drop an F it's okay no
it's not okay man because you have to
play the game you have to review the
game and you have to take your personal
biases outside of that review and figure
out the lemon gotta pay the bills real
quick
you know when I'm done I like King going
oh no no way dragons team meet with the
$5 super chat oh well these so-called
reviewers are bashing devs hard work and
insulting their work that feed their
families you don't see the devs winning
whining Wow
salute the lemon on that man I just want
to ask one question before I give it to
King as you made some great points bro
and I guess my question is more I get
what you're saying on a review aside and
I do agree with you that reviewers have
to be informed they have to at least
have some common knowledge of the game
or at least in immerse themselves in the
game enough so that they know the basics
the foundation right before they do
completely agree with you on that my
question to you though is what about the
flip side which is the Mike Ibarra part
with the whole you know as an executive
you know saying as him tweeting out you
know my question is do you understand
someone with some people being upset
about him saying those things or do you
feel you know what he's just telling the
truth and that's just what it is and we
just gotta deal with reality of the
truth like what was I to do you know
it's it's a little harder because he is
a VP right and you know you don't want
you know your VP's out there kind of
ruffling the feathers but at the same
token Mike your barber is the bad boy of
Microsoft and they have been taking it
laying down for a long time you know the
the the 1080p makes you a better gamer
this is how you trade the community
constantly Reagan on Microsoft you know
as a VP you eventually gonna get you
know fed up and you know what why I
accept what Mike did is because he's not
doing it as a VP he's doing it as a
gamer you said that because again in
defense of mine no people that's all you
kid before Mike because you play
whatever you listen the man is a gamer
first and foremost you say King and tell
you like me like don't get it twisted
like I'm not keeping for no exact if
doodle to do this fraud and I'm gonna
tell you you know you don't really play
games like this guy he plays gay he
plays games to the point I'm like Tim is
Aziz asleep hey that's my guys as far as
a gamer is respect like he no one can
look at his achievement list look at
what he does look at the hours play if
you don't believe me that
statistics are there so check that out
but yeah I can I know you want to jump
in and chop in a bit yeah okay I want
you to be um be clear with you guys I'm
gonna give full disclosure all right
Mikey borrows a Duke that's my beat
alright now I said then I've talked to
Mike Ibarra for 45 minutes and we did
not talk about anything but pop G acts
ok listen when I tell you me and him
talked about pub G we talked about pub G
to the extent that it would have made
you sick had you been a pub G fam ok um
because I live breathe and epub G I love
that game that game is actually it and
he actually is chopping up he's a gamer
so when cognero says that I had the
opportunity to my PC is sick ok my PC is
sick I can actually go on my piece I
could play with those dudes but I play
on xbox umm Cognito
plays with Mike Ibarra alright so he has
a better relationship with Mike Ibarra
than I do now with this being set I
understand the space - Mike Ibarra said
that tweet night and and I'm gonna tell
you this is twofold
it's twofold this week somebody tweeted
me and he said that we should and I told
him to tune in this Sunday that I was
gonna address it that they should have a
criteria when they're reviewing the
games we should know what systems are
using with televisions they're using
what time they spent how much of the
game they finished we should have a log
of what these people do my response to
him was we can boycott them we boycott
them and I'm talking about mainstream
media and I gotta do this in quotations
because somebody and they chat actually
said these people are putting up opinion
pieces and this is the fact if they put
down in his opinion piece as an opinion
is your opinion alright and then we
could respect you better that way
mm-hmm alright so your opinion is not
fact but I say this thing quotations
that he didn't in a chat
they said that this is what okay
this is what Microsoft should do right
and they should like talk to Mike Ibarra
to the side Mike Ibarra said that tweet
out as a gamer right right
yeah when when he didn't send that out
as an exact I want you to understand the
space that he was in when he sent it now
maybe he got the information later on
and they said to him Mike you can't do
that because he plays as a gamer first
he's actually really enraged like some
of you guys talk about that destiny
stuff and y'all not in no rate ya got
the whisper he win got the red ryx he
did it he don't have listen he's a real
gamer alright so he said from a space
now he couldn't even address the fact
that crackdown was being dragged and he
knows a good game so when he said that
tweet I understand it was a double-edged
sword because he was saying exactly he's
sick and tired of this situation going
down in this manner but people not even
having a fundamental base in that game
mmm all right so I told y'all before now
what I said right there and I had no
opinion of it right that's an ugly
mm-hmm that's integrity I don't know
about an opinion on a game that I didn't
play yeah I'm not gonna talk about
something I don't have if you don't have
an Xbox don't talk about an Xbox if you
don't have a PlayStation don't talk
about a place that you don't have a
switch don't talk about it don't sit
there and disparage something that you
don't actually own you didn't go out and
participate in that that process mmm you
didn't finish the process he was upset
that he put in this much time the guy
said that about the combos and the
Super's mmm that will piss me off as
well if I'm playing this game and I'm
putting my heart and soul into the game
and I'm having fun with the game
somebody didn't know how to supers goal
or they didn't know how the combos went
so that means you didn't even respect
the game enough to give it its due
diligence so that you didn't dig through
the game enough hmm to give it a proper
review right so understand the monkey
bars
there as a gamer I would be upset no as
an exact yeah this is the part where he
has to tread carefully right because he
has millions that he doesn't follow much
people right he has millions of people
that want to follow him and then you
also have millions of people that want
to you know get attention when you put
out a tweet of that nature the other
people is gonna jump in today and
they're gonna have disparaging things to
say about you because because you're
supposed to be this higher up
you're a face of a company that you
shouldn't do these things a lot of these
faces of companies are in gaming like he
is so when they went at him I felt sad I
was not gonna touch this topic I didn't
know how to touch this topic that's why
a lot of my words is fumbling mm-hmm I
didn't know how to touch this topic
because I spoke to the man and I know
where his heart is
axes like we know him so it's like I was
not true it's like you know it's like so
much a man you know yo he's a legit dude
and I know he's not going at the guy
with malice remember to have like 90
words or 120 words in the tweet you
don't really have enough substance to
get it across tweets are dry alright so
maybe you got told to do or he wanted to
say in the tweet with an extra he just
probably have to send it he was like boy
yeah exactly I'm not gonna say anything
else and he left it real quick cuz I
hate that about you because law boom
he's got to go he's got to take lady
boom out mm-hmm
sunday is dinner nights the Moi's
neighbor he's got to get that dinner on
with listen
salute to bull first of all for being
there for us
1000 for always showing support always
being in the channel like listen man the
love that you show us is really
appreciated and definitely reciprocated
we're gonna see you at e3 brother yes
sir you know like I said Louis a game
and dinette is here you know they're
also you will be a part of it as well
you know and I just wanna say one last
thing you I can't wait to see your face
at the press conference oh my goodness
because on stage this thousand things
laugh and I'm gonna look at your bluff
there's a goosebumps I may have to wear
a second pair of pants about it listen
gentlemen I have to say it was an
absolute fantastic forget the fact that
it was a great show it was an absolute
honor and a pleasure to be on today's
show with you guys I like I said I've
been fine you for a very long time for
me is still being a you know new guy
only 15 months in YouTube it's still or
inspiring to actually work with you guys
it's a bit it's a big deal for me in 83
2019 is happening because of your
guidance and I I go I'm always gonna be
very much in your debt for that but the
fact I'm a part of the compound growing
on an itch pictures are coming because
that place is like a mansion sick it is
boom when we put it up because I
pictures on Instagram so they can
actually see what this actually looks
like I saved this for a hundred episode
I didn't do a statue king of the statues
that I'm supposed to be doing I didn't
do it because that will be the backdrop
and you will see what we're going on so
I didn't do it but I put the pictures up
see exactly what's there I saved
especially for boom because I knew boom
was gonna be in the room I am so happy
boom is gone there's a level of
enthusiasm that he shows in that chat
and those dams I am so happy for him
thank you
it's a dream come true it really is this
is like you know I mean oh we always
joke and say you know what's on your
bucket list I've done everything in
gaming I have not done this and the fact
that I'm going at a time where Microsoft
not only is gonna have a banging show
but Sony's out and we know it's gonna be
on Microsoft now all these rumors are
starting to drop and it is it is going
to be filled Dominus Spencer no red
carpet for Boone and I appreciate that
but gentlemen listen again it's been an
absolute honor and a pleasure enjoy the
rest of the show thank you again for
including me and also offering me the
ability to write on your new
new website which kognito show me last
night I was completely blown away it
looks absolutely amazing and I'm looking
forward to doing that but gentlemen
enjoy the rest of the show
congratulations on 100
let's get another let's get another
country in there and like I said III
2019 or bust if you already know brother
I'm gonna see you man we wanna take care
of him later King man finish up yes so
as an exact something that shouldn't be
done but I respect his opinion I believe
that he wanted to tell the guy you know
least play the game all the way through
at least learn a combo at least give
your best foot forward you know your
children go to school and they don't
give their best foot forward on the test
you scold them right so I mean I'm
pretty sure that he said you know I did
this you could've did this as well and
he getting paid to do this I was doing
this for fun so um but it looks bad in
the sense that Microsoft has though
what is it the arm or a marketing deal
it's all about so does optics that's
what I like yeah ain't happy it's a bit
like he said but the thing about that is
it if you don't even have to know the
man who follow his timeline to know that
you know the the statement that he made
wasn't outwardly like a diss towards all
journalists I feel like it felt like
there was a sort of a piling on
mentality would journalists in general
I'm not saying a everybody right there
was some people that I saw that had
reactions to it but it was it was a it
felt like it was perceived as a slight
on game journalists period just go and
jumped in on that - yeah yeah I mean
listen I mean the only thing I said I
just felt bad because I know his
intention was not at gain journalist
percent say his thing is look at a
multitude of different sources of
reviews and then form your own opinion
you know I'm saying so I get that aspect
but again you know we alluded to you
know as far as who he is in the
perception but let is I want to get you
in on it man before you die on this time
like um you know you're breaking your
little Marshawn Lynch contract for a
second if you had just
yeah I mean I actually do have some
stuff to say about this you know like as
an editor and there's somebody who has
run publications and them thing I I
definitely get you know how somebody can
take that astray and everything of what
was said and everything especially given
the position that somebody who's higher
up in the industry and everything and so
you would feel a certain kind of way
because it almost feels like a personal
attack but I think that the problem is
you looking at you know that you break
it down to did like a society kind of
thing and that the mentality that you
have you know is mentioned before the
mob mentality and everything where
everybody you know they're gonna jump
they're gonna pile onto it but I think
that he's also in the tweet he's also
he's putting a good point because I
didn't take it just as writers I think
that he also was pointing out things as
far as mediate just in general because a
lot of companies are moving towards the
oh well let's go the influencer route
you know we're looking at the whole EA
debacle you know why not but you know
that that's a whole nother topic like
you're seeing that they're moving
towards that kind of route so he's not
wrong and saying that like hey watch a
streamer because if you want to see how
the game plays and moves and everything
streamers out there they're just playing
the game they're not out there even you
review and her assessment or anything
like that you know you can see what's
going on with the game so that's you
know kind of these Ponyo but I think on
the other side that he has a good point
where I think that the problem is this
day and age as somebody who does run
publications and has had their hand in
it or reviews and everything we don't
hold our own people accountable for the
the work that is being put out and I
mean a good example of that is let's
move away from the anthem thing because
I think that that's just a whole nother
beast when it comes to putting a review
for a game that's a chore let's look at
the crackdown how can you give something
a low score but say they hey I enjoy
what I play you know to me there's
something that there's a disconnect
there and I feel that a lot of it is
that people they're they're afraid to
not be part of that group because if
you're the one that sits out was like oh
well this guy must be an idiot because
he gave it a high score and everybody
else is given the terrible scores so
obviously this guy doesn't know what
he's talking about people are afraid to
step away from that
so that they they want to be part of
that narrative so that they don't stick
out like a sore thumb you know when we
look at something like an anthem to me
personally in a game that is a games as
a service kind of thing that is a world
builder day one and this is why I don't
put a lot into the they hate that anthem
is getting at this moment because the
game that I'm playing today is not gonna
be the game that I'm playing a month
from now it is not gonna be a game six
months a year year and a half we see
that with destiny you see that with any
MMO style kind of game so these ones
it's a little bit harder look I don't
believe in a day one review with a game
like this I believe in a review that can
change over time review in progress with
the game exactly you know because
because of that and and I think that he
has a good point we're not holding our
own accountable in that manner because
we're letting him run with the narrative
in drive that narrative mm-hmm no these
are all great points man I mean I'll end
it with solve let you get it should wrap
up your topic forget idea yes this was a
good subject man I mean solve any final
points on this whole thing and I mean
does he mention something that was
actually and to the second part of my
question and he's specifically talking
about just meat games media in general
right and when he Mike sent out like a
follow tweet where he talked about the
modern reviews right and and what what
he felt a modern review should encompass
and he mentioned like watching streamers
playing the demo yourself listening to
what your friends think think that sort
of stuff right so my question to you
guys in that regard is and that makes a
hell of a lot of sense to me but again
it can be perceived by some as sort of
undermining the importance of
traditional games media in this day and
age and the way they do things ie
regular reviews you know sort of video
reviews but still sort of like a
formatted thing not this off the cuff
I'm playing and just commenting on the
game sort of thing so do you think with
his comments there right and in in light
of the comments that Shawn Layden made
in regards to e3 ended and the changing
importance of games media at e3 and how
has been diminished
I found it interesting the two big
executives in with two weeks of each
other have talked about this openly in a
way that you we haven't really seen
before Oh does this is this indicative
of another shift in how games are being
covered that mainstream media really has
to switch up again because I know if you
look at mainstream games media you know
initially was magazines right then
everybody had to get a website then from
the website on then everybody had to
sort of become a personality and become
and be on camera and have podcasts and
do Let's Plays and stuff like that now
it seems like there's another shift
coming and Dizzy's mentioned it
specifically where it's like influencers
and you having people constantly playing
the games and having discourse around
playing the game and that serves as sort
of your review of the game right rather
than somebody writing something formally
do you think this is a shift that's
happening again that that games media's
gonna have to sort of jump on that
bandwagon again if they want to survive
in this in this current sort of
environment I see where you going I mean
I think that this what what you're
saying in my opinion kind of represents
what recently just happened between the
Jason shuara in a young age situation
yeah um you know we do recognize that
you know youtubers they're gaining a
huge influence when it comes to reviews
a lot of gamers and stuff like that
they're going to that as a source or
their favorite youtuber or so on and so
forth as opposed to maybe traditional
you know pen and paper kind of news guy
or Internet kind of news guy you know I
think they both have a place I still
don't think the traditional news media
outlet is going to go away because um at
the end of the day still about
relationships and getting access to
information first so if you have access
if you have the information first it
doesn't matter who you are because once
you break it first you become valuable
so I still think the edge will always
have that but I can't mix off you know
streamers youtubers like this wave of
the cup being able to speak
your common folk audience in your you
know these pockets of people that agree
with you it holds wait you know I'm
saying I don't necessarily you know
listen I don't knock anybody if they
getting paid to do whatever just be
clear that you got paid right
that's a fire that you know or ei like a
lot of a lot of my big youtubers they'll
say hey this trip was sponsored by
whatever whatever or they gave me a copy
the game even me and this is going back
for you know we get stream team to say
hey thank you for giving us a copy of
the game so this way all bases are
covered you understand how this
information is being provided to you you
know I'm saying it so at the end of the
day it's it is a rising YouTube kind of
movement and it's a rising you know
streamer kind of movement but I still
think they can co-exist I think that the
the print guys have to not be in their
feelings as much you can do the whole
you think the other you did dinosaurs I
think I think you're watching conscious
shift you're watching to distrust happen
right now when certain things happen in
this manner that they are questioning
what are you playing it on or did you
get to this far when those things are
starting to be questioned then you
already turned that person off so that
person decides not to go back there and
then he tells two of the three other
people and those people tell two of the
three other people and before you know
it is a mass exodus away from you so I
believe now because my content is
basically through YouTube like I told
you before dealer reading code mm-hm it
used to be crap dealer
I mean crap gamer and stuff like that
and I'm not saying that he did anything
wrong but I just find the content on the
other three a little bit more compelling
and so I decided to just really mainly
deal with those guys now sometimes I
really don't listen to people opinion
because I don't want that to formulate
my words to come out of my mouth on this
show right a lot of times I really don't
mess with a lot of people because of
that only thing I want you to get
whatever you gonna get is genuine right
now when these guys are saying that they
don't trust these people and they're
gonna
go to their favorite youtuber because
they feel that they can trust him
because they understand the hardware
that he's using because he already told
you our way that he's using then you can
see the time that he put into the game
cuz he's gonna tell you the time that he
put into the game and he's gonna give
you an honest opinion the polarizing
thing and I believe crackdown is the
catalyst for this every youtuber that
played that game influencer that's it
like that dirty work right ah then like
because they put this influencer on you
like he's supposed to be dirty but um
everyone had played that game walked
away from the game saying oh that's like
an eight no like his it's from hell that
that multiplayers garbage everybody says
the same thing now you have the opposite
side of that where you have the
mainstream media that should be a dirty
word
um reviewing the game and giving it a
five but if Santa had fun right and at
what point in time do we hold their feet
to the fire mmm because you're sitting
there with this bandwagon thing and I
honestly believe it's four clicks I
honestly believe it's four likes I
honestly believe it's for sensationalism
to push a narrative forward alright and
that narrative is being broken to the
floor when you have a multitude of
people saying one thing and you have
this small group of people that look
like the old people my lord my god
dollars dudes they're dying you what up
young yay and this guy right I like that
guy mm yeah whatever
that's my opinion I'll pay you alright
so if he feels um but and this is for
that reason only then you use the
influence a word on a guy that actually
provocateur provocateur oh yeah that was
a disgusting work extra work oh yeah but
anyway um I just say this that is a
conscious movement and it's going to
mass exodus away from those sites where
normally we get the information normally
we trust these people because we've seen
and I think it was strategic when they
planned it putting out that EA paid that
youtuber dude not believe that was
mainstream media to make sure that that
got out so they can stop having us look
at our favorite youtuber and question
them yeah yeah yeah if I could put like
one last thing on it also you know and
this is actually rather than looking at
the median holding them responsible we
also got to look at our people you know
looking at people who are on social
media talking to them let's also make
sure that we know what we're talking
about is this a good list let's look at
you know just my last point on is Ryan
McCaffrey got a whole lot of heat
because he put out a tweet about you
know the whole crackdown and everything
got a lot of got a lot of hate the big
thing that I was seeing that everybody
was putting back towards Ryan was will
look at agents of mayhem score look at
crackdowns scored mm-hmm but they they
didn't take the time to realize that
agents of mayhem wasn't written by Ryan
crackdown wasn't reviewed by Ryan as a
matter of fact the reviewer for both of
those games were two different reviewers
so we also know they have to do they
have to be you know looking at
everything you know we can't be just
jumping onto somebody just because they
make a little statement and using that
against say King don't believe in the
Lords of gaming that bit writers confirm
and the reason why I'm also putting this
out there cuz cog kind of alluded a you
know kind of the chat that we had here's
one living you're gonna actually find
out Lords a gaming net we actually have
a review standard in you as a reader are
actually gonna be seeing what that
review standard says of what we are
looking at because we don't want you to
think that our we're skewing our reviews
based on anything else we don't want you
to think that it is based off of a
biased there is a review schematic in
place all reviewers that are
on the website have to go by that
schematic and that's how we will come to
that underlying score at the end for
them I mean it's it's what's going on in
the industry and you know we'll see if
Kings right if it's a paradigm shift is
if it's something that you know people
are being phased out or whatever but I
know for one thing know once again with
that neck about that a greedy integrity
for the people that love you don't say
you know how we do but we gonna call it
how we call it and another point that uh
dismayed is that like again you also
have to take in the fact that there are
different reviewers I'm saying
come play again say hey but you gave
this game at this remember is if it'll s
it with the same person that reviewed it
you know there you gotta take that into
account and um yeah man that's pretty
much what I got on the island let's move
on let's get this poured and we got one
more announcement by self for a new ILP
poll this week with all the latest
rumors speculation regarding xbox game
pass coming to switch and xbox scarlet
devices being revealed at e3 2019 if
proven true do you think it will be a
tactical mistake for Sony not to be
present in any capacity during the e3
news cycle hey no Sony is still the
dominant force of this generation their
games will dictate next gen B yes
scarlet head start and switch
partnership will provide huge momentum
or C I don't care next generation don't
start til get Google and Amazon say sir
that is requested those are the choices
please Rock the aisle people when it
goes up on for the Lord boost sell my
brother and more dizzy an absolute
pleasure to have you in the realm man
where can I find people find you tell
about that site man yeah obviously
you're gonna be able to find me at
Lourdes the gaming dotnet where I'll be
making sure the stuff that we're putting
up is a teacher quality of course if you
want to get in on it like we've said
multiple times throughout the show make
sure you hit us up after the show
we got an email we'll have you send that
to a we've actually received a couple
you know during the course of this drops
on deck of like right aside from that I
mean you can definitely follow me on
twitter at ID is e81 as I will be
leading the charge to make sure that we
do get a Master Chief on Super Smash
Brothers not that we're gonna have games
out there
banjo Master Chief
stick around y'all so um yeah man we got
that going on like I said shot the bull
for spending that one hundred what else
unfortunately our brother like gaming
addict he got just he could only be on
his phone couldn't join man we missed
you bro we gotta be back man episode 100
was magical and the Lord saw oh you've
got some stuff to talk about it yeah
so we indicated to you guys before we're
continuing to continue to have some
other some giveaways and whatnot
throughout the course of the year um so
now we want to announce our next
giveaway after a very successful Kingdom
Hearts 3 giveaway so the next game to be
given away by the own iron Lords podcast
and Lords of gaming dotnet through gleam
that IO will be what I think will be in
the running for game of the year this is
your flavor what is it it's my flavor
sekito hey what's up with the screen
y'all make sure y'all give exactly so
I'll put I mean cog put that up put that
link up in the chat for everybody to get
in there cuz I don't have those
credentials if we put it links up I
don't have boss yeah so guys as we've
indicated in the past this will be an
NTSC region one code only only only for
xbox one ps4 or piece such that break
and region 1 cuz we you know our UK
brothers are not good they get some love
can I get some love Canada can get some
love I believe there's for certain for
certain platforms UK can also get some
look
so definitely jump in there and once
again if you plan on scheisse ting and
coming at us from different from
different I know the Lord's now though
is out there with the banhammer and full
of faith go say it's rigged we've even
started yet just your shout to Philly oh
wow Philly Eagle brother thank you so
much thank you for the conversation
keeping this excellent content coming
I'll keep tuning it your shout out for
you in a Taser just go and add it in to
chat that is go ready but South Philly
go man really respect you out here so
yeah so so explain our solve again for
the region one or we who are we
including what countries so it'll be
reason one USA Canada and we're gonna do
our best to take care of our you care
brothers as well but the code will be a
region one code trust me there are ways
around that if you guys are enterprising
there's definitely ways around that but
the code itself will be a region one
NTSC code yes sir please get on that man
I put the link in description it will go
out on Twitter as well in our little
podcast Twitter so check that out as
well and also real quick before I do the
I'll chose out to King and everything we
got some new swag coming y'all yes if
you want to rep the site you want to rep
the movement you know say I will put the
link in the description you know saying
but uh yeah man it's out here we got
that uh Lords of gaming you know I'm
saying we moving and grooving out here
so if you want to be part of the
movement it is out there get your
premium tu hey yo I keep getting this
cut out cuz you could change the colors
y'all look you get your flavors or if
you want to do that PlayStation blue you
know I'm saying you want to do that xbox
green go to teespring calm Lords of
gaming it's in the IOP royal swag part
of the Twitter of our Twitter account um
say do not forget man we got color waves
we got a whole bunch of other items out
there man
ladies check out the shop is lit right
now you know she saw a dizzy and now we
had two cups and all that moving
you got your sweaters you got all that
you got the four you want me the gaming
that you'd be the gaming engine you want
be the XS game you won't be like King
you got that red right there you won't
be the difficult game conquer like
addicts
there you go military staff and then of
course you know if you want to be solved
you don't say you got that black on
black right there your Cubs you got
everything got the leg hey you got them
leggings ladies but you can also switch
up those colors well you don't gotta be
ready do not like you know just please
know if you see your color like for
example we gonna put it on King right
quick you know say if you see a color
you are not locked into the color if you
want to rock the car to water are move
rocks you want to get that in the black
you can do that y'all so I just want to
put y'all make it very clack at these
questions all the time you already know
the link is in the description a lot of
color waves going on long King what you
have going on what the fine people got
it you need a t to know about what's
going on so I'm a couple of people in
the chat hit man it was like yeah we
need a fraud police shirt and we need to
throw listen cognos been at me for a
minute and I've been sitting in the
background with De Niro and Shawn god
yeah Shawn Shawn um and we've been
working on some things so those stuff is
coming you're also gonna have king of
statues up in there and you're also
gonna have combat talk with the king up
in there um those things are coming but
we it's like steps you understand we
check out those shirts those iron lord
shirts check out the you know our Lords
of gaming shirts and their hats and
stuff like that check out everything and
then those stuff will be lunch we don't
want to cannibalize the marketplace as
far as you know like we launched this
shirt and that shirt is eating this
business um but all that stuff will be
available and you'll be able to rep I
just put up pictures inside Instagram so
you can actually see exactly what that
stuff really looks like up close
um you know a debuted it for you guys
Instagram Facebook Twitter our target
squad is late this cord is a braising
if you don't at me I don't act you all
right so I understand that part I'm new
the hell out of that it's to me it's too
much stuff going on in there
you know um but we are here I am so
happy that we did 100 episodes and yes
four and a half hours and yeah my head a
type of help I finished half this giant
Magnum bottom oh but listen when I was
talking about Mike Ibarra and I was
minding my words because I don't want it
to come off wrong you know because I
really understand the space that the man
was talking from so I just want you to
understand that that I really mind my
words when I talk with people of
integrity and people of power watch
exactly what I say because um I respect
those people absolute great show busy
man you still you wanted to plug
anything to you go on now we got it
covered we got that much porn in there
this court in it we got everything yeah
man listen I hit that like you're
subscribe your tremendous support man
thank y'all for the oh you know for
insane the tweets were insane thank
y'all for tail see you brother like oh
man absolute pleasure to all you guys
man your day ones in their rocket hides
in the chotto I hide in the chat with
the logo Bobby Hart you'll shout out the
hot 13 man this is web designers the man
has done a fantastic job man Lords of
gaming again you know if y'all ain't see
it you already know what it is is really
lit and yo shout to look hi Basu you
know I'm saying he's gonna have the
audio up later tonight you're in the
SoundCloud or let's modify iTunes all
that links will be in description also
the stream team lost although l-boogie
old-school style I saw you boy MJ
supports Lord Li Po and of course they
got those IOP first looks on the channel
streaming each and every week I also
want to shout out some new additions to
the stream team coming Lord sinister and
Lord I know
unleash hit me up salute Lord I know hit
hit me up as well they looking to join
stream team so we will link you up with
Petey
we'll get that popping man and King man
debut
king of the statues absolute success man
when the next one coming King Oh
as you can see right there you have
three boxes right there those three
boxes will be unveiled every Wednesday
you will tune in to Lords of gaming
dotnet you were tuned into the YouTube
channel and you say king of the statues
up um I decided this time and I'm gonna
give you a peek in because a lot of
people was talking about iron fist sores
are really expensive haha really
expensive premium situation there may be
that you know the king is no no no no
markets off you guys
you got the Anaconda and then you got
the other joint all right but um listen
I'm gonna go into detail I took your
advice as you can see there's a separate
mic over there um as you can see I have
a different stand listen I got the UH
my watch my call came in about 250
pounds spin wheel so iron fist was
actually really heavy and I put it on
the lazy susan over there and that lazy
susan was like to hell to the no brother
I had to order the new one so any statue
that I get will not be 250 pounds and I
will actually be able to 360 that for
you so we will grow together y'all will
see statues and also the statues that I
do have already that's unboxed I will
actually talk about those on the channel
so you will get to see my collection
Julio fantastic show
listen man first of all if you I listen
to kicking up kicking statues that beat
that beat alone just for you you know
I'm saying but you again yo everybody
thanks for the support
Lords of gaming dotnet is live as you
can see one last time new content has
just gone up your face all SEC review
you already see the last word is up
they're all crack there are three views
up there oh boy you go you know what to
do oh boy oh so much man and solve
already with the giveaway shout out to
all the riders all the cool scribes
everyone at the right table that support
it we have tremendous talent opinion
pieces coming walkthroughs if you can
see at the bottom tech pieces you know
I'm saying reviews we're gonna do a
little bit more we're gonna take your
feedback as well again reach out to Lord
Izzy and myself or at the Twitter at
Lourdes gaming net Lords gaming net so
I'm gonna put that in there for the last
description and then I'll yeah man
that's all I pretty much got but um if
anyone else got anything to say episode
100 was in the books thank you thank you
thank you very much for the community
everybody enjoy your Sunday and we are
out peace